[Music]
[Music]
okay
i'm ready i am supposed to checkmate
black
okay i know that queen could go here
but then ah the night the black knight
can stop me
if i go here okay so i'm gonna go here
yay i got it all right this is easy
next one why to play and win okay um
well i can go here oh ah
something with the knight i know it's
something with the knight but i can't
take this
oh why didn't i do that magnus calls in
sergey karaki new york
2016. i was in new york when he played
this
game i should know what he did
i should know what she did okay i'm just
gonna go for a queen here
needs to be something with the queen
queen goes here then king can take the
queen
uh what other pieces do i have i also
hmm
[Music]
i'm gonna try the queen here and i did
it yay
i'm just as good as the world champion
magnus carlson that's the feeling i have
anyway
i'm gonna study on accessible every day
it's time to take control of your
journey towards chess mastery
magnus carlsen introduces chessable the
definitive solution
for studying chess move trainer uses the
science of spaced repetition
to identify your strengths and eliminate
your weeks into the end game
with confidence it's a seamless
effective
and fun way to study chess choose from
one of the largest
online chess libraries in the world with
hundreds of titles
ranging from classic books through to
our exclusive
chessable courses including over 100
free courses
get expert insights from international
master john bartholomew
grand master sam shachland international
master christoph silecki grandmaster
simon williams
world champion magnus carlson and
hundreds of other instructors
get started now and join our growing
community of over one hundred thousand
chess
enthusiasts at chesable.com
chessable take control of your journey
towards chess
mastery
so this is the broadcast tool here
ladies and gentlemen as you can see in
all
its glory you can see the notation
you can also see the engine evaluation
next to each move
and also how long they spend what i like
is
computer evaluation here interesting you
get it
quicker and better as a premium member
such as yours truly
but i also like there is a chat function
you can exchange
things with people from all over the
world if you want to see something else
let's say you're watching a tournament
you want to see all the games at once no
problem displaying
i have no idea how many games there are
like 128 games at the same time
you can do even more this is a team
competition you click on multi-board
that's beautiful you can see all the
eight games going on
at once
you can see the games and standings
which is what we got i'll click around
games standings here yeah
analysis if we click on that tab you can
see that it's a great little
graphical illustration the red line is
zero that is the absolute even mark
and if the white bars are go up the
further up they go the bigger the
advantage
and the black bars show a black
advantage
then there is a database and here we get
the alternatives and we if we click on a
move in the database
bam whatever tournament or game you're
following
you click it and you open it in the
program
of your choice yeah and one of the great
things i like to see as well is
when we get a video from the playing
i like to see them in their seats
nervous
you feel the tension you feel like
you're there don't you chess is really
becoming a spectator's internet support
great that we can see that i also love
to see um
the fact that we can get in some of our
friends
to join us during the broadcast and it's
all interactive that's what we love
a lot of overview functions there a lot
of great functions there ladies and
gentlemen make sure you
take advantage of let's get back to the
commentary
keep tweeting us hashtag c24 live we
love to hear from you
ask us anything about mainly about
lauren's
life but if you have other questions
they're also welcome also send us
anything you like about
jan
[Music]
c24 live absolutely
hello and big welcome to everyone
joining us for the semi-finals of the
speedchest championship
we have a big matchup it's matt it's
mura now peter the last time these two
played
was at the skilling open the
preliminaries where magnus and maxine
drew their game
but today it's a different format a
different animal
yeah absolutely hello tanya hello
everyone it's
it's the semi-final it's it's a big
match i mean we have seen it in in
hikaru as us wesley i mean when two such
superstars clash clash against each
other then
a lot of dramas are guaranteed i'm
expecting a very very close fight
i i don't know of course magnus's
favorite
but what i have witnessed so far that uh
you know it comes down that these two
players are probably equal
up till the moment till the very very
last seconds because only hikaru managed
to beat wesley
thanks to his incredible speed with few
seconds on the clock
and this is what we have also seen in
the match between magnus carson against
vladislav because that was also a very
close match but
whenever the players were down to four
or five seconds on the clock
that's where magnus won the match
actually
you know peter for me it was really
exciting in the last semi-final which
was
which was super close it was such a big
fight hikaru versus wesley and it was
extremely insightful how wesley in his
post-game interview mentioned
that he knew before the match that if he
took it to
the oneplus one without a big lead or
without any lead at all hikaru would be
a favorite
so what wesley needed to do to take that
match was to get
a get ahead in the five plus one and the
three plus one segment
that didn't happen and hikaru came out
on top in the end
now in today's match i think whenever
magnus plays it's easy to say that he is
the favorite
what do you think needs to be maxine's
strategy in the three different segments
well what i see in this match is that if
you put on yourself too much pressure
that
yes you know my opponent is probably
better than the bullet
um that that doesn't really work out
because it adds to the pressure and
after all
the opponent is also brilliant in the
five plus one and in
three plus one section so somehow i
think you have to take it philosophical
believe that okay if you already play
this match forget about the strategy try
to play your best chess
and maybe that's if that's when you have
a chance because
if you look at it wesley also started
very well he was plus two in the five
plus one segment
he had all the chances to go ahead but
somehow maybe you know he knew it too
well that
he needs all this this lead and maybe
exactly this hindered him off
of getting one of course this is more of
a
philosophical approach as a player you
try to make your strategy and you think
that yeah i have to do it
but i'm little bit skeptical with this
uh yes i think it's going to be very
interesting to watch what it is that
maxine brings to the board today the one
thing that we have
noticed is that when maxime did not play
out his
regular favorite openings when we did
not see him with the night off and the
grinfield
you know we never saw maxine find his
rhythm but in the last killing open he
did that
and we just saw what he's capable of are
we expecting him to change
his openings or do you think that maxine
needs to stick to his favorites
especially given the short time format
yeah i think that this is
this is a very very interesting point
and let's also not forget that
uh maxim together with nepal machi are
leading the candidates so
actually these two with one point margin
so these two players
before the least of the candidates are
in a very good spot
in order to fight it out between each
other in this regard
maxim is a very big potential candidate
of uh facing magnus in the world
championship match final and that's a
huge match
and this is also a huge match bishop
because yes it's speeches it's bleeds
even faster bleeds and than bullets but
they face each other in many many games
and
um i believe that maxim has to stick to
his weapons and
you know to to call magnus out and see
you know what this is my opening come on
in a match how you gonna treat it
and maybe force magnus to sidestep and
try you know all these kinds of london
systems or whatsoever
i'm also very interested to see magnus's
reaction that
given the fact that he knows that maybe
maxim is a very likely candidate
will he deliberately try to to challenge
him in night off come on show me your
preparation
you need it for the candidates but you
really want to show it in this
championship so i think there are a lot
of lot of intrigues
curious to see magnus's decision i think
we're definitely in for a very very
exciting uh
match today uh peter and i were talking
about whether it's going to be something
like the hikaru fantasy or more like the
hikaru wesley match and both of us agree
that this is going to be
extremely close let's take a look at the
bracket so far
we've got hikaru who's been steamrolling
his way into the finals
his match against wesley was absolutely
nail-biting but he did come on top of
that
magnus has taken down our tamiya while
maxime took down aronian on his path
to this semi-finals you know peter there
was an interesting observation that i
read on chat that
uh this was this format is
more about fastest player you have to
have the skill
of the very best in the world it's so
difficult to be fast in chess otherwise
yeah absolutely and i think i also read
wesley's
interview after the match and it was
fascinating because both hikaru and
i think wesley gave very honest view on
how they were looking things and
you know wesley pointed out the reason
why it is so unpleasant and difficult to
face
hikaru in a bullet game because he plays
extremely good chess
and does it extremely fast and exactly
that's the combination that you really
need in bullet just being fast doesn't
mean anything because you will just
be hot played and crushed we have also
seen how incredibly fast wesley has been
the only difference what i could see
that uh when they were done to this
very very last seconds then hikaru still
kept the complete control over the
possession and
this is what so far i have only
witnessed for magnus and i have
witnessed
hikaru managing to to to do that and
vastly of course being brilliant but
then he was done to his last
three four seconds then he was
vulnerable and that's what he called
used
uh it's uh it's gonna be thrilling for
me because i know i have seen we have
witnessed together that in the skilling
open maxim decided to play very fast so
he was very fast but we have never seen
him
what he is doing when he's done to his
very last
maxim seconds magnus have of course
played each other over the board
in online chess several times magnus
does have a
big plus score but really in this format
with three different segments
let's get the format up we're going to
have 90 minutes of
five minutes blitz with one second
increment then we've got an hour of the
three minute splits
with one second increment and then 30
minutes
of crazy chess with a one minute
bullet i think it's really all about the
shape and the form that the two players
are
on the day when it's such a demanding
format
maxine did beat magnus in fact in the
london chess classic
in 2019 in a blitz playoff so he's got
to remember that
that moment and bring that game on
because if against the world champion
you don't have that confidence you don't
bring on that speed
magnus is not going to give a chance
so definitely peter and you know what i
like to do it's all about the
predictions
let's start with the five plus one
segment what are your predictions on
that one and i also want to hear from
our chat
we will be keeping an eye out on the
chess 24 chat so let us know how you
think about
this match and how it's going to go
peter five plus one
yes somehow i have the feeling from the
experience yes i mean the previous match
two days ago that the audience knows
much better than
myself what to expect yeah that was the
thing that i learned from from it
i have no clue i have zero really i i
haven't
absolutely no clue what to expect i
don't know what to expect
the big question is how the players are
gonna settle in the
settle in the in the match that's that's
a really crucial
question i mean how the last the first
two three games go
and uh afterwards you know what strike
me so much
in the previous match that how the
players are able to continue right away
because
this is what i feel for myself i would
just not be capable of you know that
the game finishes and you have maybe
some heartbreak
and you collapse and these players
somehow don't don't seem to collapse
they keep on going
and that's that's very impressive
somehow i feel that maybe
magnus has a more i mean much bigger
experience
in in this matches but uh i think it's
gonna be very close so
let if you want to score i say that it's
gonna be equal after the first
five plus one section i think that would
be a dream start for
maxine if he doesn't fall behind in the
first segment of the tournament of the
of the match today very very important
for him to really do that because
i believe peter just like in the hikaru
wesley match
in the bullet segment magnus will be a
bigger favorite
than the other two segments i think
maxine's best shot
is in the five plus one and the three
plus one and we do have an interesting
insight by alakine battery
something that we've been talking about
and he says that magnus hasn't been in
his best form
according to him which is something that
magnus has said in several interviews
during this killing open despite the
fact that he cruised through to the
finals he wasn't really feeling his
rhythm
so he still alakan battery says that
he's not been in his best farm but i
still see magnus
winning the match maxine is a beast
though so who knows
i think anything can happen but peter i
know we're not supposed to be biased and
it's not really about being biased i do
think that
magnus is definitely a favorite today ah
you think so yeah so you clearly pick
magnus as a favorite
clearly is a debatable word right now
but yes i think i do pick and if you
know if you have to give numbers because
that's i think the easiest thing i think
in a percentage situation i would say
it is a 60 40. i would i would take it
as a 60 40 to magnus
what about you peter are you going to
yeah that's actually a very fair
assessment i mean i
i kind of also support this 60 40
maybe 50 but yeah i mean 60 40 i i can
agree with and probably also maxine
because he
thinks that if you guys give me 40
against the world champion
then then why not
absolutely and i see a lot of uh a lot
of our chat does think that
magnus is also a favorite again chad
it's a big big
semi-final a spot to the final and
somehow i think whoever wins today it's
going to be
it's going to be an incredible final
whether we have hikaru vs maxime or
the sometimes what seems the inevitable
hikaru s is magnus i think either ways
we're in for a thrilling ride
and uh once again thank you for joining
us our viewers on youtube
on chess24 on twitch and it's growing i
mean the
the protagonists know exactly and that
everybody is soaking for the start and
they keep on
keep us waiting yeah it's they are very
professional
and bb cardinal says that it should be a
pretty good match i think magnus will be
loaded for
bear this match embryo is very very
tough i think maxine is very tough he's
a very aggressive and an attacking
player his feature style has been
incredible
i do think he's been suffering a little
bit when
when it's been online chess but we've
seen him more in his elements
in the recent times and i think magnus
especially what happened at the skilling
open final
is definitely out here looking to prove
a point
yeah and also he had this very tough
match against
levon aronia and i mean the way maxim
reached the semi-final was to knock out
11 and 11 has been also extremely tough
and extremely
strong in this format beating yanya
komiyachi also in a very very close
match so if you take a look at this
we also see that somehow i have the
feeling that this bracket was
just so much stronger i mean all that
because
there are all these blitz specialists
and fast players but i mean these guys
are just
super strong and super fast and that's
that's the combination which is really
so
hard to face you know in the matches and
that's why i think we are also seeing
all these
very very close matches between the two
two giants because
i mean how do you beat a giant it's it's
very very tough
being a giant yourself that's the only
way and i think we're gonna have liftoff
really soon we do have liftoff
uh peter just a quick question because
it's a really interesting one before we
get to the game
and it's caribbean knight who wants to
know that had this format existed back
in 2000 who do you think would have been
the best back then
i mean okay vichy was uh which he was
incredible
but uh kramnik and vichy
the three of them were very very strong
and also michael adams was
was doing very well in this format so i
guess
those guys would have been the main
favorites but take a look at this peter
maxine
taking a long think
and queen a4 definitely something he did
not expect because you do not spend so
much time otherwise
yeah definitely you do not expect and
i'm very happy that
my maxim also did not expect because
i haven't seen this move yet i mean
there are all kinds of queen a4 checks
in the gloom third in the antibody but
exactly after cd5 knight takes d5 queen
a4 and now we see why
because actually it's it's combined with
the pawn sacrifice
is maxime going to take the d4 pawn and
walk into preparation because definitely
magnus has got something up his sleeve
queen a4 check is not regular e4 there
are lots of options e4 as a main move as
well
uh definitely took maxine by surprise
and now what is the idea because
d4 can just be picked up so knight d4
knight d4 yeah but he is the hit is the
tweak that you can't
you can't take with the queen because of
knight b5 and you don't really want to
take
i mean then there is this double double
attack and if you take with the bishop
on d4 also probably white goes
i believe knight b5 tries to hit the
dark square bishop and if he
gets the dark square bishop and then
maybe play some bishop d to long castle
is going to be very good
compensation so maxine wanted to avoid
this
and he went for
[Music]
he went for castle's d5 night before
as prepared very risky position so you
just decide to develop your pieces
and castle uh i think that should be the
approach when you're playing blitz in
general
well in general this is a very logical
and legitimate
choice but often you know the the trick
is that
you signal you open that aha you see i
want to sacrifice the pawn for
initiative but
deep inside you are hoping that your
opponent will believe you
and we are not called i don't know if
it's a bluff or semi bluff or whatever
of course if magnus has played it
definitely he believes that
he has some compensation i don't know
exactly about the objective value
and the way how maxine reacted is kind
of the very natural yeah
let me just castle d5 knight before i'm
gonna go a5
if you kick my knight away with ac i'm
gonna go back and then
try to break your pawn structure with c6
or e6
and let's not forget white's king is
still in the center
and maxine deciding to reroute his
knight from a6 after a3
the only square really where you can
retreat to he's aiming for the knight c5
square
all these decisions have burned a lot of
time on his clock
he's down by more than a minute and that
is
not pleasant for sure yeah absolutely
not and it's
it's the very first game so basically
magnus signals to his opponent that you
know you're not gonna have an easy match
you are not gonna get positions you are
hoping to get or where you are
so you are familiar with i mean i want
to
this balance you right from the
beginning force you to spend time
and uh that's that's going to be tough
on
or maxim i mean he has to fight back he
has to fight back
magnus is taking a thing here and the
first move that comes to mind is
you're threatening knight c5 bishop e3
to stop it but instead magnus goes
bishop to g5 yeah bishop g5
okay what magnus says that i want to
provoke my opponent to play the movie h6
and then i'm gonna come back to easy but
maxim says no i want to get my chance
and
can he go for some f5 or is that too
much but
f5 feels like a move that that is very
much in the street okay my
maxim goes first a4 it's also very
logical
but now now magnus stabilized and this
is this is exactly the position you know
when
you don't get this typical breaks e6 c16
in time
then white just develops bishop e2
cancels and he takes
perfect control and this phone on a4
runs always into these tactics that
whenever you put your knight on bc and
trying to for example
take on fc and go for the d4 square
there are all kinds of sticks with
knight takes a4 winning the pawn
i have to say peter i'm quite surprised
with magnus's decision to allow the
knight to come to c5 so
easily uh it just felt very natural to
play bishop e3 because sure you're
provoking 86 but magnus is
maxine doesn't have to play h6 and now
knight b3 and these ideas of bishop f3
and knight d4
looks like it would be giving black a
bit of play
after knight b3 if you go short castle
do you just trade on f3 and jump to d4
immediately
yeah but i mean okay it's it's not the
end of the world you jump to d4 i move
my queen and finally how long you can
keep this knight on d4 you might have to
give up your knight
then it's already questionable you
really want to trade that strong knight
for this
light square bishop but this light
square bishop is only a little bit
dubious until it stays on fc if i
move it back to e2 or activate it on g4
then
this bishop might be very very good the
big question look at the timing
the times equalized and now he comes
back to e3
so he's he's made sure that black is not
able to jump on d4 and i think if maxine
wants to take on f3 the idea is to take
with the g
pawn and not the bishop because if you
take bishop f3 then perhaps black has
the option to go
knight c4 yeah exactly i mean and we see
that on the board
so bishop f3 keeping the pawn structure
alive would have actually resulted in
knight c4 giving a lot of play
gft is a very very thematic capture in
these positions as well
yeah and white has this dangerous
potential uh
expansion on the king side with f4 e5
taking control of the dark squares
and then also go h4 i mean
and look at this nafta 27 black can
never play c6 yeah
magnus goes h4 the knight on b6 is
vulnerable
and how do you create kanta play with
black
yeah the dream is to get a break like c6
or e6 c6 is not possible because the b6
knight hangs
is e6 an option here
yeah i mean e6 but e6 runs into bishop
b5 and queen e7 maybe d6 is that
is that something that that's a really
nice line
could bother i mean you you still have
queen d8 but
it's not i'm not sure that this is what
you really want
no this is definitely not what you want
he's gone for e5
that's interesting because bishop b5 is
still an option and queen e7 runs into
d6 so which means that after bishop b5
he perhaps wanted wants to retreat to d8
or to d6 okay e6
yeah can i go to d6 then a question does
this uh
taking on a4 capture work in some way
but i feel like i will have some 94
trick
it's it's not the end of the world and
now
slowly we are witnessing the bullet game
look at this the game has just started
and the maxim is done to one minute and
max magnus has
one and a half minute on the clock it's
it's not much of a difference
and magnus instead chooses to put
pressure on the c7 pawn immediately
targeting queen c7 rook c8 is played
and he goes for h5 i think it's still
not
so dangerous on the king side because
it's difficult for white to get the
queen over to consider
yeah but it just do this key because i
mean if each file opens and then
suddenly i open up the
a to g8 diagonal and give a check then
then it's going to be very bad news
he goes f5 but this is complete
desperation this is complete desperation
i mean it's 20 seconds on the clock it's
time to be desperate otherwise you just
get steamrolled and
he's tried to create play he's done it
by f5 but
correct or not i like the approach to
change the dynamics of the position
[Music]
yeah i mean f5 would be would be nice if
if the h5 would be closed i mean let's
just imagine white pawn on h2 and black
pawn on h7 and we would say that yeah
black has perfect counter play but
with this and look at this magnus goes
ef
very interesting it is interesting
because queen f5 a queen trade would
perhaps not have worked because after
trading queens white has this trick of
knight c7 picking up the knight on b6
so he had to take with the jeep with the
g pawn
and now look at black's king it looks
extremely exposed but the point is how
can white make the most of it the king
on e1
stops the rook on d1 from coming into
play on the g file
the only thing that white has going is
the rook on h1 i actually think it's
okay d6 so making play on the other side
but black
can take cd6 here and he's gone for it
because yeah
between these three and uh the big
question what you do because now the
light squares now the knight on b6 is
hanging and this was the danger i was
feeling that
you know if these light squares open up
and i don't see the way how you stop now
queen d5 you trade on f7
take on c4 knight xd6 is already a fork
for example
winning i think that is the critical
line here he's taken quickly
ah but of course the i even has this and
knight d6 okay this is complete now
this is the danger that peter was
talking about five moves ago about
opening the
h file yeah no i mean this f5 was
okay but with 20 seconds on the clock
maxim also understood that
okay there is no way back i mean i gonna
lose this game anyway
but f5 just speeded things up
that was quite an incredible finish by
the world champion just
extremely to the point finds the blow
makes it happen
maxine immediately ending it going on to
the next game because he knows that
these five minutes the five minute
segment is very critical for him to
score points in
and i've seen that we often see this
opening we often see the players going
for the royal appears in these
structures
in in blitz yeah
in blitz also in classical i mean in all
kinds of formats yeah we have seen this
position in the
yanya i believe
yeah yeah there was this yeah there was
this match then magnus instead of
castles played the line with knight e5
c5
so now magnus chooses the knight b8
setup
he he likes this player type of
play so knight b8 followed by knight
blizzard is kind of natural
bishop d2 is also very natural for white
because white wants to break
on the queen side quickly be there for
before black manages to stabilize his uh
forces the big question is what you do
now because
knight c5 is kind of a threat because it
hits the bishop
yeah knight e2 is played preferring that
after knight c5 he can retreat to a2 and
he's settling b2b for himself
yeah as well if you don't retreat knight
e2 then if you make a move like h3
knight c5 bishop a2 b4 b3 comes with a
tempo and you need to avoid that
uh because that pawn sacrifice just
gives black a lot of play
and now if black was to go b4 white can
just sidestep it with a move like bishop
c4
yeah he can sidestep but still yeah
before because i feel like this knight
on c5 is quite nice and
if you play a move like bishop c5 i
might just go bishop e6 and i trade the
light squad bishop
i mean i don't really see big problem
for
for black to be honest black does look
like he solved
all his opening problems magnus carlsen
taking an early lead in his match but we
know and bishop c4 played because i
think b3 was a was a threat that black
had
to destroy white spawn structure and you
have to find a way to fight that
but with a move like bishop e6 or even
c6 with the idea to go d5
is something that gives black a lot of
play in this position i
like black's position already and c6
played
yes c6 played i mean i also like this
position a lot because
okay this is a typical rule lopez i mean
this
ant is spanish because 6d3 is kind of
some anti-spanish it can be
anti-marshall-ish but basically you just
avoid any other system and
now that black managed to get his knight
to c5 and
get this pawn structure ready to break
with d5 it looks very comfortable
so far what i see actually is that
magnus is dominating not the game he's
dominating the opening phase and
uh if he dominates the opening phase
then
it's it's very very powerful
that's an interesting observation so now
d5 is a possibility immediately and he's
gone for it
without much thought and that's a peace
sacrifice he wants to go knight c6
though so after dc4 let's try that out
peter
dc4 runs into knight c6 and queen
c7 you've got bishop
you've got knight ph oh yeah you
probably take on b8 because it's nice
that after knight g4 you have the bishop
f4
internet zone and if you take on b8
that's already not
okay anyway it's nice position but maybe
the invite has time to
go f3 stabilize the e4 pawn and then
slat on d4 so
something like cdc the d8 can already be
answered by d4
that would be a dream scenario for white
but
does black has the move queen c7 here
[Music]
i mean can i play queen c7 but then
queen e5 is not a threat because you've
got d4 so perhaps white could just
uh trade on d5 and fall back with the
bishop
yeah well in any case very complicated
and now we see this
this very first line with queen c7 take
sticks
i'm expecting f3
so queen b8 on the board on f3 just to
consolidate the center
after f he's taken he's traded on c5
that's an interesting choice he wants to
go d4 next
yeah that was the other option but i was
not 100 sure if
if any of this tactical jump with knight
g4 will
do me any harm or not but maybe it's
maybe it's not maybe it's more ghost
than real stuff
so d4 played the question is where does
black retreat with the bishop you can't
go to d6 because that walks into a fork
with e5
do you maintain it on this diagonal with
bishop b6
is that is that the way to go after d4
because like you pointed out knight g4
threatens queen h2 but lots of ways for
white to counter it
he could go knight g3 he could go e5
yeah and then also go h3 next yeah it's
it's very hard to very hard to judge on
the other hand if
yeah magnus goes for the eight yeah he
wants to keep the pressure somehow
that makes a lot of sense because white
cannot sidestep the pin with the queen
because the d4 pawn hangs
yeah but okay if i do f3 for example
okay i wanted to do ideally fc with the
bishop on e3 i did not want to give up
but yeah there were too many tactical
possibilities there so it's
understandable that
maxim decided to trade it off but what
to do now
all right so white actually has rook and
two pawns
for two pieces but the position is
incredibly dynamic
and i see i see our engine our
evaluation bar
actually i can't see our evaluation bar
peter what is what is the computer
evaluation just uh in this well i mean
it's not really relevant because it says
that black is maybe tiny bit better i
mean believes that black has no problems
but
it's often that the computer believes
that i have it two pieces i'm super
strong
but humanly speaking i mean if fight
stabilizes here then it will be easier
for white to play
the big question is maybe magnus will be
so super precise yeah bishop d6 exactly
that was the point behind luke d8
that you forced some more weakness and
the h5
magnus really likes the h-pawn advance
these days we see him with white
breaking with
h4 h5 and going for the maid and with
black going h5 h4 so the moment there is
a weakness
with g3 or g6 the h pawn marches forward
and it does look like he's created some
weaknesses around the white's king very
often when you've got two pieces for the
rook the whole idea
is to expose your opponent's king
because you want to create an attack
and now he could also look at perhaps
transferring the queen from queen c7 to
queen d7
he's gone knight h5 hitting the g3 pawn
magnus is really provoking white to push
his pawns
yeah and look at this vashi s maxim said
enough you know i want to be active
myself and goes look a5
this this is very interesting because if
you go g6 then he might just take on h5
look h5 and then queen d2 and suddenly
start his
his own agenda on the king's side we
might be seeing that g6
on the board so a sacrifice with rook h5
because he's gone queenie one keeping
things under control
perhaps well that after queen detube
that was bishop f8
trying to keep it all together trades on
b on c3 i like this trade because it
opens up the queen file now magnus's
queen is eyeing the b2
square if required and when required
and how are we evaluating this position
because
to me it just looks like a game for not
three results but two results either
white wins or black wins yeah but now
there is also some
danger you know there is some uh he goes
queen b2 i was
calculating the line ag bishop take gcd
but it did not work
finally but it was also super sharp i
mean just
very quickly take a look i was spending
some time on this line we check
because where do you go with your king
king you have two runs into night this
leaking
g1 runs into night this and you lose the
knight you have to go here and then even
some move like king g7 followed by luke
h8
looked very very messy but of course
it's very hard to understand where it
leads
so queen b2 was the more natural we look
after bishop d7
magnus down to 30 seconds on the clock
maxim a big time advantage and the
position is
is anything but clear so this could be
maxim's moment
to bounce back he goes g4 taking
advantage of the fact that black can't
go knight f4 check because the rook on
f2 will then hit the queen on b2
so the knight actually has to fall back
he's gone for
h3 first that's an interesting move so
king h3 would mean that the g4 pawn is
on the pin
and perhaps gives black the chance to go
king g7 rook etch it so sidestepping all
of that he goes king g1
yeah and queen b6 i mean uh incredible
how
magnus feels you know this this kind of
uh
all intermediate moves hc not queen b6
they seem not to work together but in
fact they do and that's that's why it's
quite amazing that he keeps such a
vision
i was just thinking about that just
looking at the whole board because you
see
h3 and your focus is on the king's side
but then he finds this counter attack
with queen b6 hitting the rook on a5
something that's very easy to forget
that
it's hanging and magnus really playing
tempo by tempo and the move queen b6
will make possible knight f4 on the next
move because now the rook on f2 doesn't
hit the queen on b2 anymore
exactly yeah that that was the big point
behind queen b6
and now it's maxim's turn to think
because if black gets knight f4
and you are forced to trade on f4 and
black bishop ends up on f4 then
this pawn on hc bishop f4 is almost like
a winning structure by itself
and maxim is burning his clock
he is going down to 30 yeah wow
yeah he probably practically had to do
it good or bad he had to do it
right peter but this
and now magnus just blitzing out so he's
up a piece
but for three pawns but that doesn't
really matter because i think
it's white's king that's under a lot of
pressure with that pawn on h3 which is
really killing
all squares around the king and creating
back rank weaknesses he still has rook
f1 so it's not made but looks
very close
yeah this is practically over and not
the clock situation
he picks up the c3 pawn
this is over peter this is over
chat this is over
and take a look at that maxine down to
six seconds but time does not matter
right now because his position
is in shambles yeah i mean it's
checkmate and just finishing it
beautifully for the second time in a row
bishop
f2 take a look at that rook f2 runs into
queen a1 and king h1 runs into bishop f3
or queen f3 made
bishop f2 another beautiful roundup by
the world champion
yes so far i mean magnus is dominating
the match
the big question will he yeah and he
keeps on you know this is typical
because
and maxine sidesteps with bishop d7 okay
[Music]
so magnus sticking to what he played in
the first round and took maxine by
surprise in grimfield now it's not easy
to surprise a player like maxime in his
pet opening
but the first game really went
incredibly well for magnus and he
repeats it but it looks like maxine
maybe with his trainer or with his
second or with
his friend has managed to come up with
some idea for this
i'm not sure if if they are involved yet
but
definitely if if the match continues
like this then he will need
he will need support because in order to
fight back in order to get
chance he needs to get uh nice
possessions i mean
positions where he can he can play but
maybe
i mean this a5 is a very nice
very nice touch
so the point of a5 is that you want to
go night before hitting that c2 square
which would be a
family fork if you allow it and also
kills the queen on a3 with a move like
night before
magnus sticking to his plan of going
h4h5
and hitting on the h file knight e6 so
what he wants to do is bring the other
knight on b4
and queen a5 is not possible because
knight b4 would then be
absolute disaster for white the rook
would hit the queen
lots of threats on c2 it looks like
maxime has this figured out because take
a look at the time situation peter
magnus down by a minute
yeah down by a minute it's a very big
question whether
uh maxim is just bluffing thinking that
okay i'm
0-2 let me just play as fast as possible
because i
had problems on the clock i had problems
with the position and tried to play as
messy as possible
or maybe it was really a very great uh
advice from
someone but i mean the game starts so
quickly how do you pass any message to
your
prodigy i just don't know physically how
it's possible
i think how it's done or how i can
imagine it is that you know whoever is a
trainer that they're working with or the
friend is following the action
so while he went on to that second game
perhaps uh
you know he got some help during that
time that okay if this happens again
try and go for this line because you
definitely get the feeling that maxine
is more confident
and better prepared for queen a4 this
time
yeah definitely or maybe he just finally
after the game he remembered yeah that's
what to do another way to try to get you
know this this is not just i'm
uh trying to find some ideas that when
you see that
your previous game is about to end then
you just don't resign
you wait like 15 20 seconds and during
this time
already you get some message or
something for the next game
and queen these six on the board and uh
riska core is saying that is he looking
at a naka fedor
recap i really hope not because we all
want
a a close match magnus leading by two
points but
a very critical game for maxine peter
because i think
he needs to bounce back right now if he
goes down by three points that's just
too much of a distance for the world
champion
versions sorry i i predicted that
after the five plus one section it will
be equal score so i really need maxim to
to bounce back yeah i want him to get
confidence because if he gets confidence
then i'm pretty sure that
he he can get a very big fight and
that's what
i don't care about the final finally
okay he calls in the final it's
fantastic but i think the audience was
the biggest winner that
we could witness this great match
between these players
all right so eight six played and maxime
thinking where to move the bishop to me
it looks like you have to go bishop f6
but
that doesn't really run into 94 because
you have queen b4 check
why is maxine thinking what is the other
alternative to bishop
f6 yeah the position is just so complex
for example i mean how to evaluate this
this type of position as well because
this bishop is trapped it can be
captured whenever he wants
iron bishop f6 e4 ah that after knight
xcc there was e5 intermediate move
trapping the bishop that was the trick
that's actually a really nice intermezzo
and the point is that the next move you
don't pick up the bishop you simply pick
up the knight and the black
bishop has no square to move exactly
so that that was the trick and after e4
a4 had to be played
and now it feels like it's it's more of
a bluff yeah we have been praising
uh maxim's preparation or maybe
preparation of bluff or whatever but
magnus is calling the bluff and so far
he's doing great
so magnus simply falls back with the
queen to c2 but this does allow an
additional
tempo of knight b4 hitting the queen
one more time because he needs to either
play that or knight c3 the problem with
knight c3 might be that white can still
go
e5 and you don't solve your problem of
the bishop
yeah you don't solve and and okay knight
db4 no he goes knight takes easy very
interesting what
what does he ah magnus just takes back
now b takes c3
interesting i mean maybe this e5 was was
possible but
maybe it was just too complex because uh
previously it was i believe winning but
with this a for queen c2
there was some square for the black
queen with queen e6 to pin the
pin the king and magnus decides not to
go for the complex lines and picks up
the knight on c3
and immediately maxime hitting in the
center with e5 i think these breaks are
so
important in the grim field you have to
get a central break
to manage to equalize your problem but
in this situation there was no other
alternative because the bishop on f6
actually stands tracked if you don't
play e5
and now magnus thinking how to react to
this
move bishop e3 is something that
definitely comes to mind
to keep the development going but i
think what black wants to do then is to
grab on d4
and go queen b4 check yes somehow bishop
is he's a desired move but yeah
black seems to be ready for it and look
at this magnus down to 35 seconds on the
clock
i mean he needs to be practical yeah and
this bishop takes asic short castle
lighting just says that okay you know
what
i mean i don't want to be provoked i let
me just play natural moves i have a good
position anyway
and let me play as quickly as possible
maybe even he will take at some point he
takes e5 i would not be surprised
interesting in caribbean knight is
actually informing us that
apparently queen d6 was a horrible
blunder
we'll have to go back to that if we get
time because we know that
right now the action is pretty hot and
the world champion is down to 30 seconds
maxime up by two minutes on the clock
yeah i mean okay queen d6 was just a
blunder because this h6 will not this e4
and uh
[Music]
and uh he could not take i mean i simply
believe that maxim thought that
e4 is never possible because he takes on
c6 and the pawn on e4
is under attack but there was this
intermediate movie d5
but okay let's let's focus at this this
stage because
maxim needs to convert this one peter
because you know he
solved his problems magnus is really
down on the clock
if magnus survives this uh that would
that is not good news for the for the
french fans
at all knight e5 played you don't want
to pick up the pawn on e5 because this
diagonal of a1 to h8 would be
absolutely monstrous after bishop e5 de5
queen e5 there's bishop b2 queen c3
coming in
so maxine decides not to go for that
instead he plays
bishop b5 bringing that rook on a6 into
the game
he could always go rook d6 or rook e6 or
rook c6 when it's possible
bishop f4 taking advantage of the fact
that the e59 hangs he plays c5
and now actually magnus is maybe just
much better because
once maxim missed the chance of taking
on e5 and
let him go bishop f4 okay be one uh
how do you protect how do you protect
your bishop from b5 and
magnus is down to 14 seconds but he has
one second increment if he gets a
clearly better position i think then he
will be merciless regardless of the time
and uh the the fact was in my opinion
that if
magnus would have lost this game or if
he loses this game then he will be very
angry because he will remember that
he was completely moving out of the
opening peter bishop d2 now
isn't that game over well it's kind of
game over but queen e5 it still
continues
bishop c7 queen g5 has to be played to
keep the support on the
on the b5 bishop or queen h5
and then e5 perhaps is e5
this is this is the point because if
maxim can
continue the game then i think that he
has chances because magnus is
just down to five seconds on the clock
and queen g5 e5 was not possible because
a bishop c6 would
which would threaten mate on g2 so queen
g5 was the only move
queen h5 would run into e5 and now a
queen trade between c1
wow three seconds on the clock
yeah i mean let's see how magnus will
handle this because
maxine is playing bullet game but
i mean he has one minute advantage you
know one second on the clock
this is maxim's chance he has to do it
maxime scores his first win a much a
very important one the game starts off
immediately but 2-1
we've got a match on our hands
absolutely i mean it was
very very crucial and i mean
minus was not only not only leading to
zero but he had a golden opportunity to
win
win a third game effortlessly because
right out of the opening
once he leaked maxim there with this h5
and h6 then things got completely out of
control
but time yeah we see the time is so
important and
if you manage to hang on like maxie
managed to avoid
i'm pretty sure we have seen the bar
jumping very high that
magnus is completely winning but this
queen g5
kept the game going and the move f4
which probably would have won
was uh was finally not played by magnus
the chat is going crazy about the fl
about the fact that maxine just flagged
magnus in the last game
we don't see that happen every day yeah
absolutely not and in the five plus one
segment yeah it's not three plus one
it's not two minutes not one minute
chess it's
it's five plus one there is an increment
yeah
yeah it's it's incredible yeah
and now we see a complete i mean the
position
looks like a caro come but it's not
exactly like a typical karokan since
white spawn is on d3 usually this white
pawn is always on d4
but the structure itself with e takes f6
is
is very much in the type of
spirit
knight d7 okay this is this is somewhat
strange i mean
one could argue that white has a very
nice position i would just say that yeah
it looks like
you are the one deciding when you take
the black bishop on d6 but
uh i mean black's position is is with
the solid with this structure
when magnus says you're not going to
take that bishop anymore because he
simply falls back with it and now he
wants to
he wants to try and get f5 at a good
moment to hit this knight on e4
away from the center queen b6 also
attacks the b2 pawn
i wonder if white missed his opportunity
to take on d6
yeah i mean it's it's the typical stuff
that magnus
let's let it happen so he played the
move 97 basically signaling that
i don't mind if you take the bishop and
then exactly because of this
feeling that aha my opponent actually
doesn't mind if i take
then you feel like okay i'm not gonna
take it but one move later you might
regret it already
it's too late to do any of that so now
queen b2 runs into rook b1 and you pick
up the b7 pawn so the pawn is still not
hanging that would be a lot of play for
for white so definitely black is not
going to go queen b2 here
he goes bishop d5 what black again wants
to do is play f5 on the next move
yeah just to stabilize the structure now
queen c7 i'm expecting
are we going to see a repetition with
queen c7 bishop f4
well it's it's possible but
it's still unlikely i believe but let's
see
[Music]
just so diplomatic in your answers
always
no no simply the point is that yeah
maxim is
one point still behind and here's has
divide pieces you know if he
if he tries to i mean it's too early to
play for foreign bishop the bishop falls
back you don't want to give up the
bishop pair on e4 so you fall back with
the bishop and he's six
and now the question is so he i like
what maxine is doing he's going b3 he
wants to advance d4 he's defended the c4
pawn
and immediately magnus decides to take
advantage of b3
by hitting that pawn structure with a5
a4
but actually he could have played d4 you
know he could have played d4 because
bishop b4
can be answered by knight cc and why
could have got harmony
but it's it's again you know you feel
like after a5
i have to stop bishop b4 this is blitz i
mean in a rapid game
you might after like 10 seconds you
realize that uh
okay i i don't have to worry about
bishop before but
he didn't blitz you you don't have this
10 seconds in every move yeah you have
to
go with your instinct and if you say
that you think anyway that is
a useful move then let's let's just do
it a tempo
yeah queen c2 it's it's very hard to
very hard to judge and very hard to play
for for both sides i mean okay white
wants to go d4
because then bishop f5 runs already into
knight xf6
tricks so if black wants to activate his
bishop then
he should maybe do it now it's another
question that maybe
he wants to go h6 and f5 but
it's it's tough yeah let's just say you
go h6
i play d4 you go f5 i go knight cc and
then for example after knight f6 i can
play a move like bishop f4
it does seem like i have control i even
don't have to move this
bishop and we see all of that happen on
the board he's gone for knight
d2 instead so perhaps what he wants to
do after knight f6 is reroute the knight
to e5 through
f3
yeah or not to play bishop f4 yet to
play knight
yeah okay it's i'm not not i
somehow i felt like knight cc was more
natural but okay it's it's very hard to
very hard to say and i believe magnus
has more experience in this he takes f6
structure because
i do remember him using in the karo khan
main validation also
fourth move knight f6 and taking ef6
let's just remember the game against
duda that completely crazy game from
stavanger
tournament and knight f3 aiming for the
e5 square magnus stops it with bishop d6
in turn he will be looking to jump his
own knight to e4 at some point
a move like c5 you never want to make
with white because that would give the
d5 square to black
for eternity yeah this bishop d6 was my
concern and then i realized also that
even if i placed my knight on cc black
steel had bishop d6
then there was one argument that with
the knight on cc maybe i could have
played 92 insisting of using the f4
square
and now oh wow so he's gone 95 peter
taking advantage of the rook on e1 so
that when your queen comes to e5 he can
jump bishop b6 and a discovered attack
and pick up the rook so you can't really
pick up that pawn
uh id asia knight g4 played attacking
the e5 pawn
and you can't go bishop f4 because there
was g5 coming in and then black would
take the e5 pawn with the knight
just to quickly show that that didn't
work so he had to go queen c3
again the e5 pawn was immune because of
the rook on e1 and discovered idea so
black just trades the knight for the
bishop
and now aiming to double on the d file
i actually like black's position here
peter because
there is no way for white to fight for
the d file
exactly and not just this but also the
bishop on g2 yeah i mean the bishop on
e6 is so much more useful
which upon g2 hits this uh very strong
blacks phone structure with b7 c6
it's the ideal i mean let's just imagine
black pawn would be on b6 then the
bishop on g2 would make
perfect sense and yeah you take the the
the open file you double with the looks
i mean
especially in the blitz how do we how do
we defend such positions from the right
side it's not easy
very difficult bishop f1 he wants to
play rook d3 and he's gone for it
because
it's really the only way he needs to
trade off one pair of
rooks to neutralize this file but black
gains control of the d file
anyway so white wants to go rook d1
next if black was to take rook d3 bishop
d3
queen d7 white would simply fall back to
either c2 or e2 and then get the other
rook to d1 and that's how he plans to
fight for the d
file yeah well but if you move the
bishop then i might enter with queen d2
i'm not sure you're gonna be able yeah
so you perhaps it's been played we might
see queen d7 and maybe the accurate way
to go about this is to play rook d1
first
and then yeah but but still i mean there
are
all kinds of tricks with a4 as well i
mean
look d1 queen d4
but queen d4 okay also pawn is hanging
you can take bishop c2 it
it looks quite quite solid
so the question is he's gone for queen
d7 i am expecting white to go rook d1
played
instantly and peter yamu a4 on the board
yeah but um
the big question is what happens if you
move your bishop like bishop c2 i don't
see
how the screen sacrifice work yeah queen
d1 it was my
and now he's going to take on b3 and hit
the c4 pawn
yeah but okay then the b7 okay black
black has all the chances to make a draw
but i mean not more
he's taken on beat three the b7 pawn is
attacked but i think
black is going to go rook d4 or roxy one
to hit the c4 pawn and create
he decides to defend the b7 pawn instead
you know i think that maybe one of the
mistakes magnus had that he missed that
the look on d1 is hanging he felt like
after queen beasley gonna play b5
use the pin and then play with queen
bishop against screen and he's the one
who is calling the shots
now he's on the defensive end down to 20
seconds
i think that's very insightful peter
there's a big chance that that's exactly
what happened
missing that the queen on b3 hits the
rook on d1 so no time to go b5
instead now magnus trying to create play
on the king side
with g5 yeah he needs to get his king to
g6 but
i mean white's position is so easy to
play right position is very easy to play
the duke from d7 can never move
and white has also some ideas like queen
before queen c5 and then a6 break the
structure take on c6
it's uh it's looking bad yeah and i
think this the last few moves by black
just demonstrate that magnus doesn't
know exactly what to do here he's just
trying to hold on
like a fortress but the problem is this
plan that white can always go
a6 when he's attacking the c6 pawn
and magnus has managed to gain some time
on the clock
he's up by 16 second the way he's
playing it's clear that he's looking for
a fortress here
yeah he's just trying to sit down but
yeah white's king on east is very very
solid and
now i'm expecting somewhere this uh he
goes c5
and queen b6 and a6 is an idea but after
queen b6
black can play bishop d5 so he's gone
queen a4
rook d5 hitting the pawn and now he
gives the c6 spawn
yeah which has to be taken yeah and i'm
surprised i mean what is what exactly is
his idea
uh he goes a5 and he says that thanks to
this e6 bishop i'm covering c8 and
it might not be so easy for you to
so black's plan to create a fortress is
to somehow trade the a pawn for the c
pawn and just say that you can
never break on the king's side that
makes sense but clearly
maxime has a different plan he's gone
for e6 break
i like that because now always there's
queen c3 checks on the board
yeah of course e6 is practically the
winning move because you get
access to to the dark squares to the
open-end king and
you also have kindy for king e5 king f6
idea that's why manus had to play look
c4
down to 10 seconds each
and now next threatening king d4 because
then rook d1 wouldn't work he
first hits the rook and now he got king
d4
yeah and that's it now it's kind of it's
an incredible play by maxime
and knocking d6 king e7
and then queen fha queen king f6 and
checkmate yeah that's it there's a mate
on g7 coming up
maxine washington equals the score
peter your prediction looking good right
now
well it's just the beginning i don't
know i mean
this this match is going to be crazy
just just the previous one
i mean it's completely out of control i
mean
the logic has finished completely
because it was not like
maxim was playing so fantastically the
last two games that he didn't give
magnus a chance but somehow he was the
one who
controlled the clock better and he was
the one who got
more lucky you know i've gotta love the
chat because
uh in the beginning everyone felt that
uh
magnus was the favorite and everyone
felt that very strongly but now with
these two big maxim wins
everyone's saying go maxine go mbl
well i mean everybody understands that
that's what we need to get a great match
and and we are seeing this great match i
mean
i'm pretty sure that uh i mean i did not
expect anything else but after the first
two games i was really worried
i mean i was really worried i have to be
honest
but okay now everything is under control
we can enjoy the match fully
[Music]
and this is very interesting because
it's it was like uh
anti night of weapon with certain bishop
c4 but actually it
ended up some kind of ruby lopez i mean
a typical
spanish structure where in anti-martials
we have seen this that
white was going for the d5 square but it
turned out that
this d5 square is not as important in
these positions
and because strangely enough uh black
can just uh
create his own agenda her own play
without really paying attention to this
and i love the way max seems playing
he's really going for the king side
attack
and knight e7 wants to transfer that
knight to g6
and just start pushing those pawns
as yas would say push them baby
yeah okay it's not so easy to to push
them that's the point
because thanks to this very nice i mean
this hd knight h2 is a typical way off
you see how the queen is
controlling the h5 square
and magnus made sure that he
his phone lands on a5 this is very very
important because he wants to play a5
now the pawn on b7 is fixed so he has
his own trumps on the queen side
but if black manages to to push
something here
and he goes g for wow i mean
this is i mean what is this exactly
it's it's all very interesting yeah h
take g4 but how you proceed yeah fc you
had to
and then i believe his idea after gtx is
to play bishop f6 bishop g5 so
gtx is maybe not but okay it's also two
pawns then i can go king jit for example
just gf
you go bishop f6 i go king g2 i put my
loop on h1 i go knight f1 knight gsd
and says that okay my knight is coming
to f5 and i'm two pawns up
i'm not really understanding this
h5 played as well i mean maxine said if
i give one pawn i give a second pawn let
me give the third pawn but magnus after
grabbing two he rejects the third one
and just makes the stabilizing of king
g2
and it looks like that's all he needed
sorry look at this king on a7 thanks to
the bishop on bc this king is in
in big danger what what was maxim
thinking about
not much that push and baby strategy
just did not work
at all peter and this bishop on b3
opposite color bishops the king on 8 7
is in is in the kill zone the only
square is to g6
all white has to do is play a move like
queen e2 queen e3
queen h3 rook h1 played black's idea is
to go queen g5 at some point
but even that can be just simply met by
f3
if white gets a successful queen
transfer to the h file it's all over
but i think what black intends to do
next is go rotate it and trade off these
rooks
yeah but i mean in this structure with
the good bishop against the bad bishop
if you treat too many p
you you only can survive if you manage
to trade all the
all the heavy pieces then it's okay but
if just
one pair of looks remain then the end
game is hopelessly lost
and even with queens on the board it's
what bishop f6 now maybe g5 queen h5 is
just
checkmate i mean it's
but okay g5 bishop g5 queen h5 king f6
it was not complete
i mean and now the bishop on g5 holds
the eight six square definitely a better
bishop than the one on g7 because now
the eight
seven square is controlled by the queen
so the rook hitch one doubling up on the
h file
is not as threatening and now black has
as well got some ideas of going rook f8
and creating a target along the f file
yeah i mean if you you go to cafe it's
it's a game it's a game we all want a
game that's all we ask for
yeah and magnus goes luke h one and one
queen after rook after king if king f2
queen f6
queen f4 what white has is rook g8 rook
f8 so the ideas of activating the queen
doesn't work let's just quickly show
that and now rook to it
and rook cafe next would be
yes it's the same yeah so this is the
idea and in this case
it was i mean basically
aha but queen d7 okay it doesn't really
matter basically what i wanted to say
that
uh magnus was in time to change one pair
of loops which
means that the f file will not be so
important
but okay black has if he manages to
trade all rooks
then there are chances to survive you
know we were talking about how black's
king is the one that's in the kill zone
but why
black has managed to create some threats
against the white king as well
and i think queen d7 a very interesting
move f3 to defend the g4 pawn
again taking on f3 just doesn't give
black enough but i like
moves like queen b5 as well maxime
decides to go
queen g7 forcing magnus to take a
decision with that rook
now that it's attacked i do think peter
that
maxine has solved all his problems
around the king
yeah under king yes i mean and there is
this potential idea that
but the duke takes effeat luke takes
effect bishop e6 followed by bishop f5
is one idea but you are still in time
with luke h8
and then you are kind of solid if you
trade the rooks then even if white gets
bishop to f5 you just sidestep with king
f6
and you want to trade everything on the
h file
so it's it's not elemental it's not
trivial at all
it's not trivial he's gone bishop e6 and
now rookie chait as you suggested peter
the whole point is to trade off all the
heavy pieces
white has two extra pawns but the
blockade on f4 and g5
make these pawns a bit of a non-event
yeah
now i i you really feel that black is
kind of
out of trouble because the point is that
even if you play like queen d1
and i trade on h1 for example bishop f5
check
something like decided to show queen d1
so that you are able to capture with the
queen
i can still insist on changing the
queens because i'm starting bishop f4
and
i would get active myself and we are
seeing
something similar i mean maybe maximum
escapes in this game
and kudos to maxime i think very
resourceful play after getting into a
lot of trouble right after the opening
those
crazy pawns sacrifices which it looked
like
magnus just sidestepped the entire
attack and went on to pick up the pawn
spree
but maxine found his way to create
chances
and now it looks like everything's under
control because after the trade of the
rooks bishop f4 queen aged two threats
white will perhaps have to trade off the
queens as well and
that should end in a draw i am calling
this a draw
yeah i also have this feeling and look
at these mangles down to 20 seconds
basically
i mean he has to realize and he's of
course
peace right now because he knows that
yeah he he was winning
he was literally he got sloppy and yeah
we see that
people i mean the players just trade off
everything
and white would pick up the b5 pawn
black picks up the b4 pawn
white has got two extra pawns but
opposite color bishop and a blockade on
f4 and g5
there's nothing that white can do the
bishop will go to c5 control d6 control
a7 the king comes to g5
and everything is fine
yeah everything is fine especially
because maxim has time yeah because
that's the i mean white gonna activate
his king towards d5
and post some problems with king c6 that
how you
exactly gonna defend these things but i
mean it's dangerous if you only have two
three seconds but
when you have more than a minute it
should be enough to understand how to
deal with it
i believe that black's ideal square for
the bishop would be on c5
as your king gets closer yeah maxine
basically made sure that he's even in
time to take and now he gets back with
the bishop to c5
and this is not completely drawn
and there we have it almost uh he even
goes like this okay this is very stylish
this is very stylish yeah
and that's it that's a draw so two and a
half to two and a half
uh we've got another 35 minutes almost
of the segment remaining
i have to say peter maxine has been up
on the clock in majority of the games
and in this format that really counts
for something
yeah i think that after losing the first
two games a little prematurely exactly
because he faced problems in the opening
he was then
playing too slowly and he was under
pressure
both on the clock and on the board he he
decides to
sidestep this and also magnus had
sidestep
basically it's a little bit strange for
me that magnus after getting such a nice
position from the spanish
switches because simply there was no
reason to switch
i mean it it looked like things are
under control
and now he picks up the karo khan which
also suits maxim very nicely because
here
maxim is in no pressure of showing
something
he can always get some nice normal
playable positions to play with
[Music]
and frodo with a hot take that mvl is
simply
faster he will kill maxime uh he will
kill magnus in the 3-1
segment wow that's uh that's a very bold
prediction i have to say
but yes in this match so far we are
seeing a faster maxim
while magnus has been struggling on the
clock
a very very close fight
yeah but i think it's also we should not
be fooled by this
simply the point is that when you are
playing the five plus one segment you
feel like you have time to think and
i'm pretty sure that once we will get to
three plus one
then magnus will adjust his play because
then he knows that he has to speed up
right from the start
but in five plus one usually you have
the feeling that you have some luxury
until you don't and now knight d5
[Music]
95 with the idea of stopping bishop f4
hitting the bishop on e3
i don't know if white can be too pleased
about giving up this bishop
no not at all not at all
i mean basically i was explaining that
against the karo khan you always get the
chance of playing just something i mean
i don't feel like this is exactly what
you are
dreaming of playing because black has
solved all his problems
bishop seven two bishops on the board
four magnus
no weaknesses looks like he's gotten out
of the opening
in an absolute dream way d4 controlling
the e5 c5 square
also perhaps wants to activate the
bishop to d3 but take a look at this
peter he decides to go for long castle
and i really like this
because magnus can aim for a question
okay yes cc b4 this is this is very
typical
you know what i wanted to mention that i
don't think what any karaoke
black got the two bishops after like 12
moves i just can't recall any game ever
being played
so in this regard i feel that this is
already some kind of a
new development in chess history because
because this was impossible but i mean
this long castle was maybe too ambitious
i think that magnus was carried away by
too much l foreign
i got such a nice dream possession but
exactly with long castle
he gave maxim a chance to justify his
play
because if mangos would have played
short castle white would be the one
feeling that
okay how do i play this you can't so
long immediately i get the game and look
at this
after letting the white knight get to e5
it's already looking good for white so
bishop g6 and the aim is to try and
trade off as many pieces as possible
maxine says no
i want the attack jumps in with the
knight to c5
knight d5 played is he going to go queen
g3
eyeing that diagonal he chooses queen f3
yeah because he's eyeing also this pawn
on f7
it's uh of course you can protect it
with luke hfa but
it hit 5a6 and we can black structure
even further
i mean magnus in big trouble here
bishop d6 certainly a much better move
than what i
proposed with luka f8 because this is
much more harmonious
this is much more harmonious
still i mean white white has a dream
possession and
it's a blitz game it's not only about uh
how
nicely you have i mean how nice position
you have but
how easy it is to play and now why it
has all the moves in the world while
it's so difficult for magnus yeah
finally he gives up
his his bishop heavy-heartedly
definitely heavy-heartedly
and now white really wants to break with
b5 while black hasn't
really made progress on the king's side
so
if white gets a successful b5 break uh
peter things could turn very ugly for
magnus
yeah i think it's already even ugly
because you know it's such position that
i would
tell you that okay you can make three
three moves
after another and still i will be better
with the white pieces yeah and that's
that's already signals that how passive
the position is
maybe he needs to go knight b6 and
knight d7 yeah he goes knight b6 he has
to trade
he has to trade this powerful knight
from c5
yeah that's a really nice defensive plan
yeah but bishop a6
for example bishop a6 knight d7 this is
a very
tactical line and let's try that peter
let's have that on the board while the
two think bishop a6 you can't take on a6
because knight a6 is a fork
so you've got to go knight d7 but then
does white have the option to take on b7
which he must because otherwise there's
knight c5 but how yeah because bishop b7
knight c5 okay you still have bishop c6
it continues because
if you move the knight i mean knight d7
you have look b5 check but it's answered
by knight b6
and then you kick the bishop out with
luke's seat it feels like white is not
in time to get a4 a5 in
and magnus is taking a think i'm certain
that he's looking at the bishop a6 line
after knight d7 can white go
knight b7 instead of bishop b7 yeah but
then
yeah he goes bishop bc because then i'm
taking on e5 in the temple
right and that uh magnus decided maxine
decided against it
and he fell back with the bishop i still
like white's position
yeah white has a nice position on the
other hand it's black's position is now
much better than it was few moves before
i think bishop c2 is a very important
move it does trade off the last uh the
last minor piece but the point is that
bishop on g6 was controlling the b1
square for the rook
and now white can at least try and
double up which is why magnus
immediately strikes in the center with
e5
giving white no time to go rook b1 rook
b2 yes so he needs to pin
yeah look see to look c8 on the board
and the question is how does white react
to this now
yeah it's a big question yeah he was
queen e4 basically he
he wants to slather d5 simply so if you
take
ed4 white just goes queen e7 so you
can't
take on d4 that wins the game
immediately
that wins on the spot because rookie 7
rookie 7 and then you have
actually wherever the queen goes there's
a mate peter with rookie 8 and rookie 7
so instead he decided to sidestep with
the rook
yeah g6 first d5 look d8 yeah queen h4
and
this is very very nicely played by maxim
i mean
attacking the h7 phone you kind of
invite it to h5 then
when white finally gets to play e6
because
getting it immediately is possible but
you have to watch out for the d1
checkmate at the very end
why i say it's possible because after h5
e6 look e6 rookie 6 fp6 you have
move like queen f6 which is quite
promising
but on the other hand maybe you even
have time but
but maybe not once you i mean black
plays the movie h5 maybe he wants to put
the look on e6 and just
sit tight in this regard e60 and maxim
says
immediately i want to use this i want to
destroy your structure
and he should trade off a pair of rooks
he's done it now queen f6 hitting the e6
and the g6
pawn yeah yeah this is
very very unpleasant queen a5 here
no i mean i like a6 i like e6 because it
creates a lift for the king
yeah i mean you have to evacuate this
king as far as possible
at the same time white collects all the
pawns on the king side that's that's the
big
problem and queen e6 rook c5
you still can't take rookie 6 because of
rook d1 being mate
so queen e6 on the board rook c5 will be
played
and now even a move like rookie three
peter just keeping the c3 pawn alive
and you've got these you've got an extra
pawn on the king side
yeah but i mean this look on c5 serves a
very nice purpose
and uh black king on a7 will feel very
very secure queen f6
maxim wants to control the dark squares
he wants to maybe go doki a check and
then queen d4 pinned this look
also maybe just to play gc kim g2 to get
out of
all these back rank issues qf6 is a very
nice move
very nice move indeed with rookie 8 in
the air and he sidesteps it because
after rookie 8
king a7 queen d4 he does have c5
so he's played queen d4 threatening mate
which is why he went c5
immediately to intercept this queen and
now
you don't want to play c4 because he's
gone for c4 i was just going to say that
how doesn't that run into rookie
king a7 queen d4 rook it well it it did
i mean it looked terrible but also after
queen d4 there is not much of a
difference
yeah and also in that line the
difference was that black had queen c5
as he's played right now yeah but i mean
okay the end game looks
completely lost i mean just takes takes
g4 and you you start pushing these pawns
and your rook on e1 is beautifully
placed just stopping black's king from
coming to any defense you've got your
counter play i think just a trade-off uh
of the queen
and maxine could be on his way
yeah and first look at czech this was
very very important because not queen d
a check now it's not end game night
checkmate
so where's the mate peter rookie six
king b5 queen d7
and that's it that's it that's it that's
game over
yeah i mean
i think that we are seeing exactly the
same what we have seen in
in the hikaru versus was leading 2-0
i mean not 2-0 but three one after four
games
and uh and then hikaru took the uh he
took the lead after winning three games
and now
maxine has done the same
this is incredible chat
maxine takes a lead with one point
and 20 minutes about 20 minutes
remaining for this segment
[Music]
this this this is not a very typical
line of fighting against the
night or i think it was level naronian
who
started playing this against grishok
maybe in saint louis then
also levon played it against magnus
maybe in the banter blitz series i
believe and then magnus himself was
playing this year we have
against guili a lot of lot of
developments here
it also shows that how much respect the
top players have for
for najdorf and they know exactly that
in order to fight against the night off
you have to come up with new ideas it's
so heavily analyzed and
usually top players know it so well that
you feel like
in the blitz game even in rapid but
especially in the blitz game you
you want to you want to sidestep it
and fish 45 saying that this was
unforeseen
that maxine taking a lead i think uh
i think i mean these are the world's
best players in these formats definitely
not expected but again
too soon to call it anything but this is
exactly what you need to fight the world
champion in this format is
a lead in these in this segment and the
three plus one
yeah and now also very interesting to
see whether maxim will be able to
to hang on to his lead because one of
the things i thought yesterday
was the problem of of vastly that
whenever he
grabbed the leads hikaru came back i
mean he called
bonds back right away and you could
never really
settle in with aha now i'm in a
comfortable situation yeah it was always
that the struggle was on
and if you manage to keep that lead for
one two games
and the pressure is always on your open
and that he has to come back
then then he might be burning too much
mental
energy but if he bounces back
immediately then he kind of
gets this lithium that aha okay whenever
i'm
uh getting auto things get out of
control i'm able to bounce back
that gives you this nice mental state
then you start believing in that that
you are always capable of doing it
but if maxi managed to to keep this
psychological pressure on the open and
then you know you will always feel this
that yeah
somehow i'm not able to equalize
knight takes c6 and and this is the
first thing
black cannot capture with the b pawn
because bishop takes c6 and now
white got a stable stable structure with
bishop d4 this is already something
magnus can
start building on bishop fc
this looks like the kind of position
magnus really enjoys playing where you
can potentially see a magnus grind
bishop f3 hitting that pawn on d5 it's
it's an isolated pawn that's not going
to go anywhere and magnus can just
the only thing is that the knight on c3
can't move you know ideally you want to
move that knight bring it to f4 and play
c3
but white will have to waste some time
in doing that
yeah maximum immediately goes loop c4
just a tiny little move but
disturbing coordination not so yeah d2
it might run into 94 at some point for
some tactics i mean not yet but
you always have to keep an eye on but i
wonder if black should go rook c8 here
peter just to make sure that the knight
on d2
is uh can't really move anywhere but
like you pointed out that currently
he's gone group d8 because if you move
that knight black has the jump knight e4
yeah so basically the knight doesn't
want to move away from cc because it
he ties the d5 pawn the end magnus wants
to go okay d1
bishop takes f6 bishop takes f's if
knight takes d5 is
is always in the air it's sometimes it
leads to that low position
sometimes it's just very good and now
maxim goes 90 for what is this
so if i take knight e4 d for bishop
takes e4 he wants to go bishop
g5 i believe that's the that's the trick
this balancing the rook you have to go
kind of i mean if you want to keep the
bishop but then the
the pawn on c2 is hanging we might be
seeing this
so bishop g5 rook d3 on the board rook
d3 looks like a forced move because
bishop e3 you just pick up the rook on
d2 and pick up the bishop on e4
so you have to go rook d3 played
and now rook c2 picked up immediately is
there any tactics here with
with bishop e3 well i mean okay my
bishop on g5 is protected i'm not
uh worried that much about it but yeah
my duke on c2
is is the one that i have to pay
attention so even maybe a move like
bishop cc can be
can be played tricky position
it does feel like there should be
something now
the point that why i thought about he's
gone bishop g7
oh wow but this should not be such a big
deal because after king g7 you pick up
the d8 bishop in the end
and then black just plays rook b
is hanging so if i take on the eighth oh
yes
oh yeah that's actually really a good
point because after king g7 rook d8
bishop d at the brook on c2 hangs
and actually black has to play rook d3
here or move the rook away
yeah he's gone for the trade but this is
not just a healthy bonus and with this
time
ma control with 2 minutes 40
seconds on the clock i mean this is i
believe a relatively easy win for magnus
bishop g7 another very very
uh very strong tactic by magnus i have
to say that we've been seeing he's
really
very his vision is extremely strong
today peter we've been seeing him finish
off games in style find these tricks
uh while maxine has been keeping an
upper hand on the clock so really both
players
showing their their different skills
yes basically i mean okay it seems like
all the games when
magnus one tactics worked on his favor
but in those games that he lost it
looked like
uh yeah he he was missing things yeah
it's just a very intensive match and i
feel like
the players under i mean maximum
understands that he has to play very
fast so he deliberately take the risk of
maybe missing something but uh the
chance of missing
him missing something is still very
low and that's why he take this this but
this g4 bishop f1 going bishop g2
musician he needs to keep both bishops
on the board otherwise it's just game
over and bishop g2 b6
so if white goes bishop d4 he's gone for
it the problem with b5 could be
that bishop b7 could create problems for
black spawns
instead he goes bishop d8 and
now can white just go f4 and start
pushing
the pawn and bring the king with king f2
king e3
exactly i mean it looks like there are
no hopes
i don't know i just don't really believe
that there is any hope here
the only hope is the time factor because
magnus down to one minute 20 seconds
while maxine has
over two minutes long term weakness you
put bishop e4 you can
if there is no way from black to stop f4
you go kinji to king
fc king he's the and then f4 if he stops
with bishop c7 if he doesn't stops then
even here you don't need to push it yeah
king g2 that's
perfectly perfectly right
and black trying to trade off pawns on
the queen side he needs to do that he
wants to get b4
in uh the more pawns that get traded the
better it is finally
magnus decides to go f4 it's time to
play king f3 and f5
b4 played uh you can't go a4 because
that would come under attack with bishop
b3 or bishop d7
trades it off and now
white does white want to play f5 next
well i mean white has only one problem
that he has too many good ideas
i mean just advancing now the for
example
g5 and then just advancing on the king
side but also the pawn on bc and also
the pawn on b4 and it was weak that
white can even just march with his king
towards the queen side and that
should be also but yeah magnus goes for
straight
g5 and fg yeah that's the most i like
this i like this because the h pawn is
the strongest passer that you can have
and he's created it
so now he could also go bishop f3 and
he's gone bishop e5 the main idea is to
try and push the h pawn
king f4 next all right so g6 is in the
air he defends it with bishop c2
king f4 h5 is an idea now
yeah i mean okay just look at white's
bishops yeah they are
attacking and at the same time they are
controlling everything but he needs to
be a little careful now because after h5
black has bishop d2 king g4 bishop d1
and white could be in trouble with the
pawns so h5 currently is not possible
can he go bishop
he's gone h5 what happens after bishop
d2 now okay he is still king g4 bishop
d1 check
king h4 bishop e1 check bishop g3 but
i mean why but then you trade off
and yeah and then your team g7 and you
want
f6 and you have all the chances to hold
i i'm not getting did
he has to trade the h pawn for the b
pawn so the point is that bishop b1
bishop g3 you pick up the h pawn you
lose the b3 pawn but that's
very few pawns and now king g7 f6 coming
up peter
yeah i mean i would love to see
magnus's face right now because he must
be furious i mean just
this is too much he cannot be happy and
this is just a draw
this is just a draw i mean what you miss
what a big mess and now just the king
comes
king f7 king e7 you just bring the king
to b8 and
it's game over just keep your king on b6
or b8 and move the bishop around
and it's a party yeah
he could just go king d8 king c8 and
king v8 here
he's done it he's done it
yeah which means that magnus has to
be with the black pieces to equalize
just to to make my prediction
come true which which i'm not believing
anymore
maxim might take the lead in the five
plus one section
red ribbon saying that this is a world
championship preview it very well could
be because magnus and miyan navamiyachi
are leading the candidates currently and
uh
i think the candidates will resume
sometime in 21 spring is what we hear
uh we are halfway through with that
we'll have a challenger to the world
champion
sometime mid next year and it very well
could be maxine
so it's always very exciting to see
these players play against each other
yeah absolutely i mean and this is
i think it's it's very good for chess
you know whenever you see that
it's not like this that magnus carson
comes and wins
it's clearly he's the favorite he's
somehow
better than everyone else but i mean
all these challengers are so incredibly
strong that
i mean basically magnus really has to
play
extremely well in order to to prove that
he is he's the best
it does not come automatically that's
what i want to see and people
usually think that ah of course you know
it's it's automatic no no so
follow everything because chess has so
many surprises
for everyone
and dutch defender with an existential
question that perhaps maxime
is better than some of you seem to think
[Music]
well i think those who didn't play
against maximia don't know
yeah what it feels like that
just try to play against him and then
you understand how strong he is
[Music]
yeah but enough i mean two moves before
then white got knight ac knight c4 in i
felt like aha okay i'm liking
white's position and just after black
was able to break with d6 d5
i feel like this is the type of position
magnus can be quite happy with
so bishop f5 black wants to bring the
rook to d8 and start targeting the d3
pawn
uh the question is how is white creating
play knight e3 immediately asking black
to take a decision
he trades off rook t8 is an option he
goes for b6 c5 pawn was hanging he could
not have gone rook d
at that moment and breaks with d4
yeah and then he will go he will pin
this knight with luke the eighth
i mean white is is uncomfortable
or the bishop with rook d8 and either
ways black looks like he's doing very
well
yeah the point was that after there was
a move knight b5
avoiding the i mean there was this
tactical trick
to get rid of the pin but like this
imagine black bishop getting to d5
i mean i see chances i see chances of of
magnus equalizing the five plus one
section
i mean this is the this is the best what
you can uh
have with the black pieces i like how
maxine is playing he's creating his
chances he's gone for the break on the
queen side he needed to do that with
that pawn on d4
and it shows that you know he's not just
gonna sit around and wait for you to do
everything
but he's got some ideas of his own own
and after ba five there's a move like
queen a4 on the board
the question is how is black going to
react to a5
queen i feel that black has to
cement his position i mean not to fall
into any provocation
yeah very important that okay a b i
gonna take back a b
or maybe a b q b but no i think a b a b
just
and get the bishop to d5 stabilize and
and start torturing your opponent
[Music]
that's how i feel about it
it's gonna trade and trades the rook
takes the chance that you can't go
bishop d4 because of the pin with rook
t1
no also you can also you can take on d4
and take on e7
that's right yeah because after bishop d
for the d1 suddenly i have e5
all of a sudden yeah but you can just
take and take on e7 and
you can also hit f7
[Music]
yeah and bishop e6 would not mean
anything so queen b3 on the board he
can't take on d4
yet he's confident he's confident
so bishop d4 queen d if rook d1 there's
e5
and so he trades off on d4
if he picks up e7 black will go bishop
e6 against queen f7
yeah and then he's trying to use look a1
and trying to also trap this
look on e7 but not so easy peter not so
easy for white after bishop e6
yeah not so easy but i still can't
believe that this is
this is so tough to deal with
but now black has some really big ideas
with rook a1 and just trying to
uh target your f1 f1 bishop even if the
queens trade off
for example a move like queen c3
black could potentially even look at
just trading the queens and going rook
a1 and now bishop c4 can only be
defended by rook c7 and b5 and suddenly
like you're you're completely lost
because there's no way to fight against
this
yeah i mean you have to be alert and
this powerful queen because
one thing uh one thing is that you
sometimes just want to give the exchange
but but it doesn't bring anything yeah
queen b5
maxim has to calculate very precisely
but
what is the difference
okay difference is that for example if
you go to k1 i have queen eight check
king g7
rook takes e6 fe 6 queen e7 check king
a6 queen fh i can dilute the king
further and further
queen c6 not queen takes e6 is a threat
that's a double attack so how is black
fighting this he's got to play bishop
bishop d5 is an option
or queen d5 queen d5 could
yeah queen d5 is an option but then you
just lose the b6 pawn
so also then you lose all this potential
of
uh of winning the game yeah yeah and
also after queen after the queen on d4
is perfectly placed it defends the b6
pawn it also defends against queen c3
check and everything along this diagonal
but now with rookie six and queen eight
on the thread is bishop d5 the way to go
yeah the big question is that uh how
magnus feels he might feel that
uh that he he missed queen c6 he might
have
i think that his move king g6 signal
that he believes that his possession is
so powerful that he can
make this useful move because he steps
away from 28 and next he gonna go to k1
but after queen c6 it seems like he has
to forget about this winning idea of
pinning white's
bishop and he might have to settle for
uh for a draw
queen c6 a very strong move by maxime
just giving no time for black because
all black needed was to get the
rook to a1 but now suddenly peter i
can't think of another move except
bishop d5
what what is the alternative for black
hill
is it queen f6 is that what he's but
then you just take rookie six so you
don't even have queen f6 on the board
yeah you don't and margus himself is
very much confused because he's down to
one minute on the clock
but i'm very surprised about that
because the more i look at the position
the more i feel that bishop d5 is the
only option what am i missing
well oh queen d5 i mean maybe queen d5
because queen takes b6 look a
one would be just too dangerous for
white so i believe after queen d5
maybe ah white gives quincy check that's
that's actually very nice and
finally after a very long thing he plays
bishop d5
[Music]
and now it's mark seems to him because
he has i mean what are
white options now to
if you go queen c1 protecting from luke
a1 then actually you go too passive
black might come in with luke a2
and otherwise you have moves like queen
system immediately but then still the
same issue comes with takes takes and ok
one pinning
and you have the move queen d6 but it
also does not stop
white from going luke a1 so he goes
queen d7
and rook f7 is a threat which is why he
had to play rookie for defending that
queen on d4
ah but this explains you know because
after bishop d5 27 if not for the k4 for
this powerful move
a4 there would have been no real defense
against luke takes f7
that's that's why mango spent his time
interesting because although queen c5
was a move but then maybe b4 yeah it was
extremely
complex which is why um magnus thought
over but he found rookie for a very nice
defense
but it feels as if all of black's pieces
are tied down somehow
you know yeah but but thanks to 2k for
actually all these issues are solved
i mean black wants to go before hitting
the b2 pawn the queen on d4 still
protects everything
also somewhere just to move the bishop
on e6 to e6
and trading the queen and you might win
opponent look before
i mean yeah maxine says take my pawn
take whatever you want he's going for
blood on the king side
h5 played and these moves are always so
disturbing magnus down to 32 seconds
he could not have taken on b2 because
then rook f7 again became a threat that
queen d4 had lost its immunity
queen f6 you can't take on d5 because
the rook on e7 hangs
and now the big question is how can
white continue to play for the
initiative he's got threats like h3
he's gone rookie too okay that's that's
an interesting move just defending the
b2 pawn
yeah because because this queen on f6
actually
protects black's king side perfectly
very important for white to keep this h5
pawn yeah he wants to in
he insist on h6 that magnus goes g5
magnus wants to go h6 himself and then
he will
kind of get this chilling mode that he
needs for the final
uh final part but look d2 just in time
to change can he change
rookie 4 is still possible because
maxim is done to 10 seconds on the clock
so magnus would
love to pawn and after
rookie 1 black white could even go rook
d6 he goes rook h4 he's eyeing the h5
pawn but that feels a bit slow rook t6
hitting the b6 pawn
no way to defend this trade peter it
feels like it's too white's favor
yeah but okay i mean the black is in no
danger yeah
he's in charge and in fact okay black is
still pressing this
it's it's pawn up of course it's
statically low objectively low but with
four seconds on the clock we have seen
it in the previous match that
the objectivity doesn't mean anything
here maxim down to four seconds
will magnus flag maxim in this position
or be able to find his chances of course
it's
it's a draw but with this time control
just anything can happen
and maxine picking up this is the final
game of the five plus one segment which
means it's magnus's last chance to
equalize the score
before moving on to the three plus one
yeah this was now of course very nice
for maxim that he managed to
cut off black's king
ah but he he lets it back to g5 okay he
did
he relies on this look b8 setup still i
i would have preferred not to
not to let this happen anymore
magnus immediately grabbed the chance of
putting his look on b2
because there might be some where some
idea with
yeah but okay now it's different yeah
bishop fc
and now there's no way to escape the
trade of the bishops
oh and this is just over because rookie
two next you trade off the rooks and you
just keep the bishops on the board
i and just king f2 because you're not in
time to even go bishop f3 because white
would pick up the f5 pawn
he will just simply still keeps going
and knocking f3 king d3 king after yeah
this was this was the profession he
played
by maxime in a tough situation and with
that
we have a wrap of the five plus one uh
blitz section
and it's maxine vashir lagrav who's
taken the lead in this match
i have to say that's not what a lot of
us expected
but maxime showing that he's not
he's not easy at all and proving a lot
of us
wrong in that peta three plus one this
is going to be a real fight
absolutely i mean it's uh it's
completely open
i mean and the way how we got to this
plus one for maxim yeah that
magnus was up uh 2-0 and we
usually used to that that once magnus
grabs the lead he never lets it go and
moxie managed to bounce back
fight back the match is completely wide
open and uh
yeah who i mean who knows what what
still is in store for us
what's in store for us is one hour of
three plus one and a lot of epic chess
we will be back with all the action stay
with us
we'll be right back
hi welcome back to the french course in
this chapter we're going to look at the
quick starter guide i will try to show
the whole repertoire in a very compact
way to take you through the
directions and the main lines and the
sidelines show you
and give you a little bit of an idea of
what i recommend
where and what type of positions we are
going to be dealing with
but needless to say uh i cannot cover
everything in just one video so
uh for more details definitely
definitely study
uh the rest of the chapters but uh
without wasting any further time let's
attempt to cover everything in just one
video so it's e4 e6 that's the french
here um there there is a chapter on the
second move alternatives
i uh look at two main ones i find b3
uh a very interesting sideline that uh
i've discovered when looking for a
surprise weapon for white very
interesting
here i recommend d5 visual b2 and now
knight c6 is a very very uh
strong idea the main point is that we um
play against white setup and white setup
here is to bring the queen out to e2
knight to c3
and castle long and knight c6 stops that
effectively if knight c3
the idea is d4 and if queen e2 the idea
is that now we take on e4 and after 93
we have this very strong move knight d4
forcing white to recapture only for with
the queen
not with knight and then win an extra
tempo with knight f6 and having one
uh a couple of extra damping this
position is very good for black
now this is my solution for second move
b3
obviously there's more details um but
that's a basic
and after d3 um of two there's the
so-called king's indian attack white is
intending to develop the bishop to g2
and uh start an offensive some sort of a
reverse king's indian
uh here i recommend a very interesting
um rare
setup of the d592 knight f69 gf3 the
move
knight c6 uh this is not the usual way
usually
uh c7 pawns uh the s7 pawn goes towards
c5 first and only the knight e6
but this is very interesting the idea is
uh to push the pawn to e5 and if white
plays in the same
style of the kingstonian attack with g3
which is already by the way quite
inaccurate
i propose to take on e4 take only four
play bishop c5 and
bishop g2 e5 castle castle
we get this interesting position some
sort of a
reversed pierc slash reverse philadelph
a very um good position for black we had
lost a tempo on the e6 e5 but it's not
too relevant the bishop on g2 is not
well placed it's staring at the e4 pawn
black has easy development the idea is
very often a5 v6 followed by a bishop a6
and uh what's most important is that uh
our king is very safe uh which is not
the case in many of the
incendiary attack uh positions but here
it is and i believe this is an excellent
way of
handling the kids indian attack and um
with that let's move on to the second
move deformed that's the main line what
most of the players play in after d5
i'll look at four main moves
um let's look at them one by one now
against 92 i recommend the line with c5
that's the main line i think it's the
best line
and uh myself i played the move knight
of six but it's not
as a kid actually so it's not very good
i had to find out i find it out the hard
way
after c5 um there are a few
options ed 25 dc5 is one of them it
essentially leads to a similar pawn
structure of knight f6 knight frequent
x5
knight gf3 is the main move of the city
xd4
white has two variations e takes d5 is
the old main line
now we take uh 25 bishop c46 mainland
goes short castle knight of six knight
b3 knight c6
knight xd4 knight xd4 and um
there's an end game which is very fine
for black uh but knight 64 is the main
move
and here i recommend a relatively rare
uh setup with bishop to seven
and short castle and uh the main line
goes c3 castle queen of three
uh queen c7 hitting the c4 bishop and
one of the important ideas that i show
in this
in this chapter is that after bishop v3
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay i'm ready i am supposed to
checkmate black
okay i know that queen could go here
but then ah the night the black knight
can stop me if i go here
okay so i'm gonna go here yay i got
it all right this is easy next one why
to play and win
okay um well i can go here oh
ah something with the knight i know it's
something with the knight
but i can't take this oh why didn't i do
that
magnus calls in sergey karaki new york
2016. i was
in new york when he played this game i
should
know what he did i should know what you
did
okay i'm just gonna go for a queen here
needs to be something with the queen
queen goes here then king can take the
queen uh what other pieces do i have
i also hmm i'm gonna try the queen here
and i did it yay i'm just as good as the
world champion magnus carlson
that's the feeling i have anyway i'm
gonna study on accessible every day
it's time to take control of your
journey towards chess mastery
magnus carlsen introduces chessable the
definitive solution
for studying chess movetrainer uses the
science of spaced repetition
to identify your strengths and eliminate
your weaknesses
there's no need to set up a board
remember which page you're on or keep
track of all the moves you miss move
trainer empowers you to go from the
opening to the end game
with confidence it's a seamless
effective and fun way
to study chess choose from one of the
largest
online chess libraries in the world with
hundreds of titles
ranging from classic books through to
our exclusive
chessable courses including over 100
free courses get expert insights
from international master john
bartholomew grand master sam shankland
international master christoph zulecki
grandmaster simon williams
world champion magnus carlson and
hundreds of other instructors
get started now and join our growing
community of over 100
000 chess enthusiasts at chesable.com
the broadcast tool here ladies and
gentlemen as you can see in all its
glory
you can see the notation and we are back
as peter was saying that before the
start of the match we were discussing
what is it that maxine needs to do to
fight back
but now the big question is what is it
that magnus needs to do to fight back
and peter according to me this is
something that we've spoken about during
the champions chess tour as well
that we've seen magnus bring out his
best when he's against the wall
yeah and we have seen the last two games
he took control i mean uh
in the penultimate game he had this
technical winning position i mean it was
like a big shock and i think uh magnus
is very very angry with himself that oh
he did not
win that game then he was also better
pressing in the very last game
so the direction is good he has to keep
up i mean he has to keep up this uh
[Music]
this pressure on on maxim the only thing
is that
when you are missing your chances uh
then
this dynamic might turn again and uh
okay maxim definitely after the break i
believe he also comes out i believe both
players will come back
like you know we have to combat the very
first game will be
very first games will be very very
principled
because if magnus comes back then he
might start
overrolling maxim but
if maxim keeps the lead then it might be
still quite a frustrating
comeback for magnus i mean i did ask our
chat peter what their prediction for the
three plus one segment is and they're
quite torn actually lots of support from
maxine especially after seeing that
performance in five plus one
we're seeing a very in shape uh mvl
while magnus
falling a little short on the clock uh
yes it's it's really anyone's match you
can never ride off the world champion
but he's facing a very beast version of
maxime today
yeah and maxim is also this type of
player that
with each victory he gets more and more
confidence and he takes it very natural
that
you know if i win it's a natural result
one could argue that
aha of course this is probably the
characteristic of all the
strongest players in the world but uh
you know i'm not 100 sure that it's the
case with everyone
but it does seem like you know with each
game he's getting stronger and stronger
but
magnus on the other hand we have seen
whenever he's under pressure
he starts delivering and the last two
games he already signaled to his
opponent you might be leading
but i'm taking over the control of the
match and it's just a matter of time
till i will be up on the score again
that's a very insightful point because
magnus was the one who was on the front
foot in that last game wasn't able to
convert that
end game but he showed that he's up for
it really it's
i do believe that three plus one is the
most critical section here
because in the bullet we've seen just
how strong magnus can be but when it
becomes blitz and when there's
a a bit more time on the clock maxime
has is really holding his own so we've
got 60 minutes of three plus one coming
up
after which there will be another 30
minutes of
fast and furious bullet uh peter we've
been seeing
interesting opening choices by both
players we saw magnus's idea of queen a
for
countering uh maxim's grin field do you
think we're going to see a repeat of
that
yeah it was kind of strange that the
strategy worked very well for manus at
the very start and then he was the one
who deviated
and this was quite unexpected and look
at this now magnus the ma
the section just started and he goes
third move h4
[Music]
so no queen four ideas this time which
we've seen earlier
after knight c3 d5 takes on d5 knight d5
queen f4 we've been seeing that line
instead uh magnus plays his favorite
move h4
very early on uh and d6
knight c3 yeah i mean this h4 line uh
strange enough became very very popular
maxim himself used it against yan yapon
actually i believe in
one of their critical games in last
year's video grand prix
and got a very good position uh
grieschuk himself
was the one who invented it they
invented it on the highest level because
this move h4 was was there i think simon
williams was the one who
who kept on playing it but i mean the
really new twist was that
uh understanding that if black goes for
the banker gambit with c5 b5
then that was like a common knowledge
that if white plays h4 in them
he moves three then black can just
switch to
banker gambit but after it turned out
that banker gambit isn't that easy
isn't that simple then third move h4
became like a
main uh weapon fighting against the
groomfeld all of a sudden
and if you just saw this position you
would never believe it came from a
grunfeld
and it's kind of like the king's indian
setup but black has gone bishop to e7
and not to g7
white immediately breaking in with h5 he
wants to either play
h6 at some point or even hg6 because
black will be forced to take with the f
pawn
avoiding all of that maxine with a very
interesting move
chief bishop e7 is 97 if you pick up the
knight on d5 the bishop hanks
yeah that's uh that's the point
but i mean positionally this movies is
quite ugly so i
i'm not really you know paying attention
to this phone yeah
just play bishop easily because usually
black wants to play
f7 f5 in all the structures once you put
your opponent on g5
you kind of fix this this structure and
the reason why i
love magnus's choice that it disbalances
again
maxim yeah he's he has incredible
reflexes in the grim fed but
being not being a king's indian player
in all these positions
what is this bishop takes e5 followed by
95 just wins the game
okay means it's it's little bit too much
i mean it wins the pawn and
gives a clear advantage for white i
don't think it's too much at all peter
this is is this just a blunder what's
going on
yeah but now black got some really nice
dark squares so it's not that easy
it's not that easy and he's also uh
discoordinated white's pieces it's going
to be a while before that rook on a1
finds himself
in the game and he goes short castle
yeah basically maybe if you ask maxine
he will say that
now i'm not happy for the first time in
this game
you know it's that's not so bad
considering that we are still very early
on in the game so he goes a4 making sure
that black is not able to create
easy play with a b5 break or go a4 a3
himself further weakening the dark
squares and
is maxine trying to go ni f5 next
yeah except this type of uh positions
why he loves to play chess
where he's so strong with contract i
mean counter play
f5 gonna come and it still requires some
time for white to go king b1 king a2
that's two extra moves
and that's how white is planning to
develop go king b1 king a2 and finally
bring the rook into the game simply
goes b6 and doesn't start with f5 that
does give white his time
yeah but he wants to go knight d6 first
hitting the c4 pawn and he says that
yeah i did lose time with b6 but you
first defend please
the c4 pawn and then i'm gonna go f5
f5 on the board now peter and
wow this i have to say looks like
maxime has really seized the initiative
if you take on e4 white can't recapture
with the pawn because that would allow
rook f2 so white would have taken knight
e4
and you don't want to open that diagonal
so he keeps the pressure on
brings the bishop back to e5
yeah black has perfect compensation the
big question is
is it enough just for equality or is it
enough for something more
because you stick with the knight yeah
he has to take with the knight of course
white's
point is to keep this e4 square and
maximum side steps with knight f5 he
wants to keep
the tension he is also eyeing maybe at
night h4 now magnus immediately stops it
with queen c1 because
knight h4 maybe can be answered by luke
takes h4 and queen takes h6
i mean all kinds of ideas like this
so white has an extra pawn but i really
like black's pieces they're all
centralized
every piece is placed ideally on the
board he's got the two bishops
and i see the evaluation bar peter it
does give an advantage to white but i
think we cannot believe it right now
yeah i mean i i would not pay much
attention to it it's
it's a bullet game i mean the players
are again done to their
less than one minute the knight is
exchanged on d4 yeah black has this
powerful bishop on d4
okay white is very solid yeah white goes
g4 he wants to
stabilize everything on the other hand
now with this fc pawn weakness
he really needs some knight gc bishop e4
knight f5 will be grouping but
maxine will never give time for that and
he wants to go rook f4 rook f8
hitting that f3 pawn immediately which
is supported which now gets supported by
that rook on e3
a very nice way to defend it he goes
queen f8 bishop g4
is a big threat on the board but not
knight g3 i mean time for knight g3
knight g3 a nice move because it also
defends the rook on f1 so bishop g4
not possible anymore he comes back he
wants to go rook f8 but there's always
knight f5 to sidestep everything
e4 i mean yeah there are so many tactics
yeah bishop takes g4
exactly the point is that luke f1 the
bishop on e4 would hang and look at the
players that down to 20
seconds yeah bishop g6 maybe this was
the move
magnus was lying but no it's uh it's not
good enough
for survival magnus has to fight for
survival and he's done to 20 seconds
and this rook on b3 is going to be stuck
there for a long time while black is
just going to
magnus immediately finding a way to open
up because he wants to take that pawn on
b6
and king e7 to defend penguin takes f5
what is this look f5 gfg4
it was very dangerous oh
yeah that looked extremely strong
because how is white defending it we'll
have to take a check on that maybe chat
can tell us if that sacrifice
actually worked did magnus have a chance
to go rook f5 gf5 g4
chat will inform us yeah nah i would not
be surprised if it ends in a draw
because
just too little time and he's not going
bishop f5 anymore because that would end
in rook f5
and that's it we've got a draw by
repetition
uh with that maxim maintaining his
one point lead and immediately we go
yeah this this is what i mean it's it's
a brutal format i mean for a spectators
it's fantastic
i mean for the players it's it's very
very demanding because you
never really have time to adjust to the
new situation
and believe me after every game like
also the previous one yeah it was such
an ups and down battle
that uh without coming down and without
making sense of it
to start a new game okay you have to get
used to it
probably the players are used to it for
someone who plays this format for the
very first time i think this would be
one of the biggest challenges just
how to start a new game right after you
had so much emotions in the previous one
but also peter these players are so used
to playing these formats they've played
the speech championship before magnus
won it in 2017.
hikaru won it in 2018 and 2019 after an
epic final against wesley so
and uh i think i think these are the
best players in the world that are
fighting for this so they're definitely
up for the challenge for us mere mortals
it does look very difficult
but they know what they have to do yeah
they know
i mean i'm pretty sure that but we also
see with all these online events as well
that the level of
the games gets stronger and stronger
better and better
the players are adjusting their play
they they've
settled in kind of they understand more
what they are
and what they have to do how they have
to treat the situation but
look at its game you force your opponent
to think right from the beginning you
tease him with some bishop c for tempo
i mean there are all reasons to to think
also peter i'm being informed by chat
that you were banged on about your idea
of rook f5 and going g4
that was a big miss by black right there
yeah i mean it felt uh right away and i
believe that you know when
magnus led the bishop on taken on f5 i
mean his heart got a hit
definitely but then he managed to to
correct immediately
but that was a very scary moment for him
and he never went back to f5 then he
went king b1 king a2 so he definitely
spotted that idea
yeah that i mean this is the typical
stuff that when you just let the bishop
on f5 taken in the very
last i mean exactly at the second when
you let your mouse go
you already know that what you have done
yeah that's that's typical
and look at this what is what is
happening i mean queen t
c six can come with check but then there
is bishop d7
crazy i mean what's going on in that
line peter after queen c6
you've got to go bishop d7 and
i see on our boat that queen e5 is
played he's still having a think here
and you take on f6 because
uh the g5 bishop hangs yeah do i have
some bishop f to check
or not oh wow i don't know it's
it's not the end you just move the king
king f1
because the e4 pawn hangs right if you
take on f6 you just go queenie
yeah you know what let them figure it
out i mean it's
it's their job we are here we spotted it
there is all this excitement
all these possibilities uh and and we
see maxine feels now that
i have to calculate because maybe it's
working but if you spend
one minute and you realize i'm not happy
with it then you regret it that's
and he goes for it okay
we see this line
[Music]
yeah the two bishops compensate the two
bishops compensate but
uh i mean what is this it's pure madness
i mean
and uh yeah maybe just fine
maybe maybe black is just fine because
this bishop on e5 will be so powerful
you know who's away with the king
because the dream is of course if white
takes on e5 you want to take fe 5 to
solve your structural problems
yeah this is also one additional stuff
yeah maxim was bishop dc
tries to keep i mean it's a
psychological battle now yeah none of
them wants to blink
they they want to keep this going and
if you can find one more useful move
you're going to do it but
don't overdo it the king g7 might run
into queen h4
and there is no way of that might be
just game over
i mean kg7 runs into queen h4 and
suddenly black
does not have queen f5 check i moved and
if you move the queen iv again because
you have to protect the bishop
yeah magnus goes bishop e6 it's
it's a stabilizing move
and look at those two queens just facing
each other neither deciding that they
want to trade and now
finally maxime steps away with queen
edge for queen g5 insisting that you
want to
improve that pawn structure he does it
maxime has an extra pawn but i think
black has full compensation here king g7
bring the other rook into the game
yeah nice it's uh symbolize the the
queen side
knight e4 knight takes g5 bishop a2
and all maxim really needs to do is just
keep up his leaves so i think
but now peter this a pawn could
potentially be quite dangerous
yeah on the other hand i mean he has so
much initiative yeah and you see this
lookie for
g for immediately creating the threats
against black skin so maybe
finally black will give up this dark
square bishop and
put get the bishop back to e6 but
if you give up the dark square bishop
then the white gets three
three rows so maybe h5 has to be king h6
wow what is king h6 that's very fearless
i i don't know if it's good fearless or
bad but
yeah that's a tough move to make
or understand finally he trades but now
rook g5 and that king on f6 there was a
rook f6
mate on the spot which is why rook b6
had to be played to stop that
but peter rook f5 he's gone rook f4
yeah i also saw that look f5 rook h5 and
and all this
but now look takes d5 you have seven
wins on the spot no
was that just checkmate no you still
have king h5 you still had king h5
yeah so g4 was was correct
and this king on 86 i have to say king
86 was a very strange move and the start
of many problems for black
does he go rook h5 and mint what happens
after rook h5 and just pick up the rook
on g6
and well he could have picked it up
immediately but
let's not forget magnus is down to seven
seconds so
just hanging on i mean i thought maximum
g5 check finish game over
that's it oops
peter that means that this is just
absolutely amazing and
the game starts immediately and we see
magnus employing the same move h4 that
he did
in the three plus one segment earlier in
greenfield he's deserted his queen a4
idea for now
and a similar similar start peter but he
goes knight c6 here
yeah and okay i i mean i like the
strategy for magnus that he has to keep
insisting with the line which works
until it works
i mean just to put the pressure on
pressure on the opponent
and look at this maxing sacrifice this
has to be preparation i mean
you can't give up this center pawn just
like that
it's impossible and that also in six
seconds i absolutely agree with you on
that
[Music]
and what is happening i mean okay
clearly bishop yeah bishop
is developed black wants to
button black one do you want to play h6
here yeah a6 is gonna be mad by bishop
f4 i believe
and then knight h5 then you take on ah
then yeah
no no i don't want to give up the dust
for bishop if i even if i win one more
pawn no no yeah
so bishop easily correct or knight g4
knight g4 is an option here
yeah but knight for them bishop f4 yeah
it already perfectly makes sense
right so he's gone rookie 8 hitting the
e4 pawn f3 just stabilizing the center
yeah i mean the move d5 would be the
natural reaction yeah d5
is played so cdcd will be
aha d1 first
i really have to say peter it's amazing
how maxine is going for such dynamic
play he's two points out but he knows he
doesn't want to play safe he's taking
his chances he's gone for this pawn
sacrifice
maxine is out for blood i like this move
queen c7
eyeing the dark square weaknesses also
just moving away from the
from the d file and forcing white to
take a decision in the center
and now not this bishop b5 i mean this
is the move i
i was pinning my hopes from the right
side because this tempo and the e8 look
and then i'm getting closer to short
castle
i need to need to get my king
away from the center as quickly as
possible
and bishop d7 unfortunately doesn't work
because you can just simply take on d7
and the d5 pawn is pinned again
yeah and it's not in the spirit i mean
if already maxim started the
gambling then he needs to gamble and
yeah he goes bishop b7
this is the move in the spirit i don't
know the objective evolution of this
move
but in a practical game good or bad you
have to do it
the engine bar hates it but of course
this is just
it's uh it's an exchange sacrifice for
for the initiative the e4 pawn is still
hanging you can't take on e4 because of
the pin along the e
file but it doesn't feel enough to me
yeah but these positions are very tricky
i mean it all comes down to the next
one two moves because if white is very
precise and then he
managed to somehow prove that movement
move
i have things under control with maybe
something like queen
but queen d6 26 look d6 efc bishop d4 ft
g2 that would be an
mezzo yeah magnus goes knight b5 he
wants to get knight b6 tempo in
no no time because black has long term
very nice compensation but
black species are still not yet
stable because this e4 pawn once you
take fe4 or black
plays he takes fc all black species are
freed up
[Music]
and magnus playing fast he's up on the
clock now queen before another very nice
move hitler
knight x e4 is he winning
it looks completely winning now that
knight e4 move hitting that rook on d8
giving black no time to pick up the rook
on f1
taking advantage of the pin again
so what happens after bishop f1 queen d8
is hanging so you can't take
you can't take the rook
yeah now it's already clear that white
is in time to stabilize yeah
so what is white's move here peter
because the rook on f1 is hanging the
knight
knight e3 is also a threat right now how
is white stabilizing he needs one
stabilizing move
what is that is it um can you just
simply go
rook would be natural but then you go
queen e6 it's
uh it's not the end of the world yet
what about rook effie one is that an
option
look everyone it's an option but somehow
you know yeah you need to calculate
because knight takes east
g7 27 you take on a6 and that's the
point but it's still very scary with
that knight on e3 although luckily black
will not have queen d2 maybe you can
just show that line yeah
i mean the line is look fe1
if black takes on e3 he's gone for it
he's played rookie one
and here luckily black has got no queen
d2 coming in because of the knight on e4
you have bishop d4 or queen d4 but then
bishop d4 could be an option there we
might see this peter we might see this
happen right now
queen a6 on the board maxine chooses
queen to d4
white has to move away with the king or
play knight f2
no actually he also has queen c8 queen c
but then queen
b6 wow that's that's a lovely trap
i mean what i was talking about that it
seems like i'm forcing the exchange of
queens but you can go queen b6
and queen takes this is mad by bishop
before check
is coming in next
it's going to pick up the knight queen
f2 is a threat so is he going to fall
back with queen e2
or rookie 2 yeah but then queen comes
from h2 i mean
you have to and look at this magnus down
to 16 seconds on the clock
and maxine has got almost a minute
yeah i mean this is this is maximus
strategy about queen d2 and then around
with the king
but queen h1 queen g2 you just go king
d1 and that no
king d3 you're [ __ ] dc hitting the
bishop three
and then you take on d3 yeah i forced
the exchange of queens and
that's a nice idea that would be very
important although there is bishop f2 in
that position
yeah but okay check and i'm hitting uv
check
[Music]
right so we're going to use g6 check we
might
see this peter we might see this is
happening
bishop f2 played rookie
peter we are just calling out the action
yeah well i mean
and queen f4 yeah this this one f1 has
to be played
this is super exciting
yeah and all these with 10 seconds on
the clock yeah with 10 seconds on the
clock and that's it
magnus carson wins because queen f7 was
a massive threat
no checks on the board queen c4 is not
an option
everything under control hg6 coming in
and
with that the world champion strikes
back
i mean very very impressive play by
magnus here because it was so easy to go
wrong
i mean all this tactical possibility
everything with very
few seconds on the clock i think magnus
can
regain his confidence after this game
maybe he didn't lost his confidence at
all but
i mean and you see he's back to this
line which we served him would in the
second game
and he goes bishop e6 now
immediately so no no more b5 before
that move actually worked quite nicely
in that game but definitely
the players understood already what
white should be doing there
so magnus deviates and nicely okay
it's now it's a typical slightly
slow uh anti-martial position but
in general i feel that black is kind of
quite solid here
luke 8 making sure that he always has
this
bishop f8 move so he doesn't have to
worry about knight f5
and the big question for why do you go
b4 or not
it's uh it's the typical debate but i
think after b4
black black would go knight a4 currently
you think i saw that i would take on a2
and go back with the knight to e6 but
that's that's also a really good idea
and we see that on the on the board
without even being provoked to do it
yeah because this knight on knight on e6
is usually such a monster piece i mean
this is what what you like as a spanish
player to get
and uh maxi might regret of uh spending
that
uh 20 30 seconds on uh
on this exchange of bishops and i think
what we've noticed so far in all
these segments is that that one second
increment
is just about enough to make a move and
not as much to really
gain time unless you're completely
winning but you know even when you're
slightly better it means nothing even if
you're a lot better it can often mean
nothing so really
uh the clock is extremely important as
important as the position on the board
in this format
and rookie one will be played to fight
for the a file
[Music]
yeah thank you keeps control can black
or queen see six rook a trying to insist
that he wants to trade off the rooks
yeah actually i expected queen c6 a move
earlier
because yeah just not to take on a2 but
it's the same idea
i think it works because of the c2 pawn
otherwise white would have time
exactly that's what time is this well i
thought that if you take t
can go queen c6 i have queen a5 but then
you can take the c to pawn now
maxim had to waste time
magnus gets the a5 with k8 and now c4
yeah this is the typical way that
okay you basically didn't got anything
out of the opening but you make sure
that the opponent cannot break later
with d5
and you try to claim that if i ever get
my knight to d5 it's something like
knight e2 knight cc knight d5 i might
have some chance
but magnus immediately goes for the c5
square targeting the dc pawn which is uh
white's weakness
and i really like that because dashan is
how does white because if you go queen a
queen a3 white also has black also has
queen a4 just offering a queen trade
exactly and now so black has all kinds
of ideas with bishop g5
i mean basically it's clear that black
is perfectly fine
even has a slight advantage because he
has the c6 form which covers the d5
square
and there is no way to to kick the
knight from c5 away and
we're gonna see g6 king g7 played by
magnus in the next couple of moves
and then play also h5 i mean the typical
way you can make all these moves
improving your possession
and for white it's it's much harder
he does the same i mean he needs to play
g3 and now magnus goes bishop g5 because
f4 was maybe a slant
i like black's position yeah i think
black has no problems at all
queen b3 can potentially come in
just looks like everything's under
control for black hair and white has got
no real targets in black's position he
goes h4
would you play bishop he's gone for
bishop d8 i was wondering if bishop c1
was an option but
he chose bishop d8 i think black wants
to play queen b3 at some point
but he has to be careful of queen a8
always
yeah well i mean i'm not sure about the
queen plate because then i feel that if
we trade queens then
white will bring his king to e2 defend
his dc
weakness and somehow it denies just hang
on but with twins on the board there is
more
more dynamic in the position you have
aha look at this queen bee
one check he wins the pawn picks up the
pawn
picks up the pawn and if the queens are
traded that is just lost so white black
white has to keep the queens on the
board threatening queen dei just ate
six now means queen eight queen c6 so
white's got the threat of picking up the
c6 spawn
but then he lose the e4 pawn
this looks like things have suddenly
gone very wrong for white
yeah but uh the point is that usually
you want to play g6 in this position but
yeah h6 is stronger because you have to
take away the gpa square from white's
knight
and now do you want to go queen 8 king
87 queen c6 i don't see a better option
yeah but then you take knight takes e4
and you are coming anyway knight e4
played queen c2 is the threat
white has gone quick so he's threatening
to go a perpetual with queen f5 and
queen c8
g6 needs to be played knight f6 is gonna
be played and okay
it's uh knight f6 is a very nice move
keeping it under control actually g6 the
more i look at it i don't like it
because it creates more weaknesses
in your camp and he's gone for knight f6
keeping it solid
but does white have c5 i was just going
to say this because
exactly now you don't want to have e4
do i have e4 how does it
go e for queen f5 check g6 queen takes
f6 e takes f
i you just go king h2 and my f7 pawn is
hanging yeah
so i cannot cannot go for that can you
quickly show that line
well if i go e4 queen f5 check g6 queen
takes f6 e takes fc king h2 and
that this f7 pawn was hanging and like
this
at least i mean now max team has chances
but now just take on e5
and queen e4 queen f5 definitely missed
by maxine because you're looking at
queen e5
what an incredible move
and that's it that's it queen h1 is bc6
queen c6 is there to control queen h1
incredible queen fc back maybe maxim
escapes
yeah this looks like now he's escaped
because i do not see a way to continue
the attack and the mating fights you've
got queen f5 but that doesn't come to
anything
small sleep he wanted to go queen f5
check oh my god
oh my god
yeah because okay this is the moment
that we want to see magnus's face right
now he would be
so angry that is a rest in peace mouse
situation wanted to go queen f5
but peter you remember in the skilling
open when he made that mistake against
yann neptu he went
queen b4 with a mouse slip blundered
that queen he was aiming for queen b5
but immediately bounced back so i think
he's the kind of player who has a lot of
tolerance of not going on tilt
but magnus needs to win this game maxine
still maintaining that two-point lead
yeah and we see the same line repeat
interesting that after 92 will
maxim again sacrifice the yeah he goes
for c5 so it means that
he believes in this position this has to
be done in his preparation
the big question is where will he
improve his
bishop e3 it's exactly what we saw
knight g4 that's the first
and we were thinking about bishop f4
there but he's chosen bishop d4 and now
knight e5 played yeah and the idea is
that after f4 he wants to go
c5 probably i mean i because otherwise
f4 would be just
very strong but f4 can be made by c5
and fe5 you take on d4 and you pick up
the e5 pawn with the bishop after queen
d4
yeah because at all cost black has to
keep his bishop alive and if white moves
the bishop back
then already i can bring the knight to
c6 and i'm coming to d4 and compensate
so magnus says no thank you i'm gonna go
along castle first
so c5 is met by bishop c5 perhaps so you
don't have time to bring your knight
into the game
or also even just bishop e3 because the
d6 pawn is extremely weak
do you think after c5 white can take on
c5
so he goes bishop e6 actually to the
idea is that you want to go c5
yeah now probably the question is can
white play the move c5 but
it's it's scary i mean maybe some queen
a5 i mean all kinds of dynamics are
coming
and uh okay it's a very tough situation
because
just like one minute ago it looked like
magnus gonna
win his last game and then he equalizes
the score and we will have
the new dynamics like magnus has just
bounced back and equalized the score and
all of a sudden it
is still minus two now for magnus
this is very very nice this is very nice
because now he could sidestep with queen
f2
with the tempo he hits the queen and he
wants to go f4 f5
closing down the bishop so black has to
go queen f6
f5 played anyway knight d5
he's going to trade and take if you
don't take with now he's going to take
on e4
but maxim having a thing yeah i mean
he's up on the clock 20 seconds it's
it's correct that he thinks because
actually his decision might be
might be vital i mean why not just take
on e4
what is it would how does white respond
to fe4 here
yeah i don't know some i'm guessing
threes on f6 and then push d6 and bishop
bishop out this is that's what's
happening and bishop will come to c4 and
try and create
uh some counterplay along the f file
with rook f1 next
yeah and to claim that okay finally if
i'm able to grab the e4 pawn
then uh okay i'm dominating the big
question is
how much the maxim will look like
king g7 because h4 is still hanging yeah
that's that's kind of
unpleasant might take the time
and the point is you want to go rook f1
and double up and now you can also go
rookie one and start hitting the e3 pawn
but then i go e4 that's typical
maxime hits the b2 pawn and then gets
bishop d4
that's what he wants with easily that is
actually a really nice move peter to go
e3 with the idea to give up these spawns
you don't care about it what you care
about is the activity of the effect he's
creating his play his agenda and
all of a sudden maxim is just in time to
change the dynamic and get his
he impose his will on the position
yeah magnus goes look he won e4 he has
to take yeah
i mean he doesn't want but he has to he
he had no right to allow bishop d for
protecting the easy pawn
you should be two king c2 the bishop can
always come back to d4
which is a really nice square but he can
first even play f5
to just cement that pawn on e4
yeah that's a lovely movie f5 and then
bishop d4 back
okay white will always have look beastly
but it's not like a winning attempt it's
more like uh holding
i wonder if magnus is if maxime is
considering bishop d4
directly here but bishop d he's gone for
f5 i think this move makes a lot of
sense
why give the e4 pawn and bishop d4 next
i really like maxine's position here
yeah but i mean also duke d5 was an
incredible move played the tempo by
magnus
because he knew that he has to activate
his look to d5 because
if the duke gets cut off then his pawn
on d6 is gonna fall and
whether it's good or bad i'm not sure
that you can judge it in
within few seconds but you have to go
for it you have to go for it
d7 so now white black has to trade
because rook b8 and d8 was a threat and
now king
he has to go king e7 next he's gone
bishop e5
he keeps his chances but this is looking
white
white shouldn't be in any danger now at
all with those two c6 d7 pawns
yeah absolutely and the bishop on c4
does incredible job of
protecting these two pawns okay one can
argue that black's bishop on gc as well
but
i mean peter maxim has bungled up
somewhere big time in this end game
yeah well this duke d5 was very strong
for my i think he might have missed this
b4 idea that
he is in time to just break and look at
this magnus is
about to bounce back or not
not that clear yet
i mean let's not forget this king and
this bishop yeah with king d6 it's
it's an incredibly solid setup maybe
black is just fine
look at this very untypical stop but
very effective
and i think the point is that after
bishop d5 black also had rook f5 so he
gave up the c6 spawn
but now once again
things looking fine for black yeah
looking fine the only
question because how how do you treat
this position it's not
very tricky bishop d8 he wants to
he has to start pushing the e pawn at
some point he offers a trade a rook
trade is an immediate draw
so is magnus going to keep it alive or
will he rely on the next game
yeah he's gone for it that's it that's
it
controls all this diagonal can he so
bishop d4
stopping your king from coming in no it
shouldn't be
and now e3 king c4 is met by each other
king c2 exactly that's what i meant
because this
books are too far away i mean uh
but peter you cannot anyway enter isn't
this just a draw because uh
you have no way to enter with your king
yeah but i mean no i'm settling now king
d6 now i'm coming i mean i was
threatening king c7 and king and that's
it it's one zero magnus
wins that's it because there's no way to
fight against king e6 king f7
and that is a classical magnus grind
and creating something out of nothing
yeah absolutely but i mean it was
incredible i mean and also
when when maxim played look f6 it
immediately hit me that
you know it looks like you you think
that it's a drawfur because
uh it's it's exchanging of exchange of
the rooks but in fact uh
this is very tricky with two or two
passers like this
and we see this karo khan
[Music]
i think this line is supposed to be fine
for black i think this line is supposed
to be fine for black
the question is does black just sidestep
to move bishop f6 or does he not care
about it
yeah it's a good question yeah e5 is
placed cc
so he decides not to care about it but
it could not have been taken in that's a
before
but okay this this e5 bishop a6 is
slightly mysterious
i mean if it's good it's good but i mean
it can also turn out to be unfortunate
so after b4 white wants to go bishop c4
he goes
knight d5 instead f6 is a potential
threat
yeah f6 is a set but this position is
not completely out of control i mean
strategically speaking maybe even some
bishop h for bishop g3
okay maxime was first and this was the
point peter that after f6 says queen h5
so which is why i think it's just a
potential threat but not a real one
yeah yeah but still i mean
it feels to me like black's position is
slightly artificial and
uh if white gets two moves in like look
if he won and
he sidesteps with the queen he will be
simply be better
magnus goes c5 but doing that with the
king on the 8 i mean
it requires a lot of lot of courage
you should d3 hitting the pawn on b5 i
think a move like c4 you want to provoke
that because then you really stabilize
uh
your center but if not c4
wow black just answers with shut castle
yeah
yeah and now finally he gets this this
harmony and i'm not sure that
this losing time for bishop c to bishop
dc was was justified
now it it all makes perfect sense look
at this magnus got a very healthy
[Music]
position
maxim wants to provoke some weakness on
the other hand
okay magnus goes for f5 immediately
judging that
he will get immediate counter play with
b4 is that what he wants but
is it so easy to get because it's clear
what he wants to get but b4 maybe i have
knight c4
maybe you cannot go b4 then is that
knight f4
i mean no but
on d2 i'm controlling the f4 square and
now the pawn on e6 is weak
right knight f4 you just trade on f4 and
pick up the pawn on e6 so that's why b4
was not possible he decided to trade off
the knight and goes rook f6 to defend it
also white has to be careful on
potential threats along rook g6 the g2
square because that queen on b7
could be something and ideas of b4 are
in the air
yeah this is i mean it's fantastic if
black gets in
b5 b4 also and changes the light square
bishop then he might
remain with a very powerful knight on d5
on the other hand those structures are
not so clear because seemingly you have
a
good knight versus bad bishop but white
gets a lot of activity
things are far from clear maxim goes for
ac
he wants to make sure that he opens up
the
e file after b4 i think b4 still peter
it just looks very tempting to go b4 now
because like you pointed out that if we
trade off the light squared bishop
there's a good knight versus bad bishop
position and that's quite the dream
but maxine he's gone for it he's gone
for the idea of b4
has to trade
but he has bishop takes before trick or
not i mean can he
just lick with it yeah he he does knight
b4 was met by queen b8 queen before but
then that means that that's an extra
pawn right now
yeah it's an extra pawn which is enough
to compensate for the powerful knight
but
uh another big question where do you put
this bishop you go bishop c5
but then the bishop ahab yeah this is
this is the way because the bishop on c5
would be out of the game but bishop on
e5
that's where you want to have this
bishop the bishop on e5 is very much in
the game
eyeing the g7 pawn that's actually a
really nice way of
solving the problem of where to put the
bishop yeah but
exactly you go look f7 and then you come
now the b to pawn will fall
then queen f8 and you maintain the
threat on g7 so it's going to be
very interesting he of course offers a
queen trade yeah queen
queen b7 rook b7 rook b1 runs into
knight c3 so you don't want to play that
instead he goes queen d6 he wants to
keep the pieces on the board
hitting the e6 pawn i think a queen
trade is definitely black's dream but
maxime is he going to be able to avoid
it
relies on some rook c6 idea he doesn't
want to defend his
v2 pawn h4 exactly okay black king on h7
might
feel also insecure now c6 tempo
loki seven so black wants to go king f7
and go rook b7 next to activate this
rook
yakking h2 and he chooses king h5
does he want to go g5 he wants to go g5
yeah he wants to go g5 yeah
[Music]
he wants to trade off as many pawns as
possible and
uh if fgfd should take fgfg now black
can
get his king to f509 to f5 eventually
also
but g4 pawn is a weakness
can't take it because of rook b3 check
but he can repeat withdraw cafe
rook g8 wait what he's got king h4 he's
got king h4 so it's still under control
[Music]
yeah i mean after king h5 but then he
had luke b8 so that was this look be it
possibility for white
and now rook g2 is a threat so he moves
away with rook to g7
and knight he prefers some knight is the
idea
wants to bring that knight to f5
incredible play by both these players
down to seconds
again maxine slightly ahead on the clock
yeah it's it's incredible i mean
when you look at it then things look
quite normal and everything but i mean
the speed they are making all these
judgment and their moves is just
incredible i mean this is
for example now so it's it looks like
two pawns magnus is down to eight
seconds he has two pawns done
what is happening what is happening i
mean night looks like
it's it's very bad five seconds but he's
got two extra
bombs sorry maxim has got two extra
pawns this
this is looking winning for
knight g4
but still not easy never easy with a
knight and rook there are just so many
checks and tricky jumps and you could
just end up in a fork before you know it
but okay this is this is winning
and you could just queen as well you've
gone for it
yeah i mean incredible performance by
maximum i mean
amazing peter oh just died because he
just couldn't take it anymore i mean it
uh it was obviously too too much to
handle
now you're gonna see a night off bishop
c4
now we see this line again
so the engine bar has died so please
don't pay attention to the engine bar
the game will be in equal mode
throughout this game
we will fix it in the technical break
after the three plus one
section this is incredible maxime
leading by two points and we're almost
at the end of three plus one segment
potentially another three games but
magnus really has a lot of ground to
cover
and the way it's been going peter as
well i would have before it started
would have placed magnus as a big
favorite in the bullet section
but maxime's control over the clock has
been
phenomenal in this match yeah incredible
i mean incredible speed
but the big question will be when it
starts with one minute then
then how things will turn but we are not
there yet
what we have witnessed this however that
maxim is leading by
two points i mean that's that's a big
catch-up magnus has to do here
and looking at the position it seems
like black is perfectly fine
i mean nothing to worry about two
bishops okay white has
very solid structure white is not
running any degrees but
i mean it does look very comfortable for
black
yeah definitely thinking about getting
f5 in and he goes for it
he goes for it yeah i mean maxine wants
to stay true to himself i mean he knows
that this is his type of chess he has to
uh he goes bishop c6 okay interesting
giving the bishop d5 option of course he
trades it off
yeah and now he has
queen b3 okay yeah you have to take the
a5
like black's position here knight c4 is
that but it doesn't it doesn't have
because of queen d5 you've got queen d5
queen b5 queen d3 so that's not a
possibility
yeah knight b1 is played white wants to
go knight ac somehow
hit black's weakness on b5
and promote b4 because then white would
have eventually a possibility of placing
the knight on c4
which is still much easier said than
down because that pawn on d5 will be
hanging
the black doesn't want to give any such
chances and keeps it all consolidated
with rook be eight and go c4 so he wants
to plant that knight on the b5 square
exactly quite a nice spot for the night
yeah that's
that was one of the strategic dangers i
was
i was feeling in the position that yeah
here this b for knight b5 and then okay
one comes
and if bc then takes takes knight takes
c4 is
uh black will have to have some look bc
counterplay
he has to do it and he's done it but
white can also go rook d1 just keeping
things under control that bishop on
the dark square bishop is quite unhappy
currently
brings the king now he's going to free
the rook from the d3 pawn defense place
it on a1
bring it into the game magnus has found
his chances
yeah definitely black has to go e4
because he needs this dc square
i mean after d f he then look a1 he
always has luke dc
hitting the d5 pawn it feels like
it should it just should be enough to
to be fine for black
[Music]
yeah you have to take take and king d2
okay so yeah magnus wants to kick the
look away with king c2 and
if he gets it he might have chances
mangoes might have chances
but how how do you deal five rook f7
trying to create counter chances on the
f file this is very nice
because he finds the weak spot in
white's position and immediately goes
for it
yeah a tempo so king moves back king d2
and black really needs the bishop on d4
but
it knight xd6 always comes with a tempo
hitting the loop so it's not so easy to
sacrifice this pawn
but he could play king e2 rook f5 move
the knight back
to e3 m and then you can come back and
try and get your bishop on g7
that could be a plan king e2 played is
black going to go for rook f5 he's gone
for rook b7 he wants to go
rook b4 trying to move the knight away
yeah
and also bishop g7 already is is in the
air as well
maybe rook a4 maybe white has to play
the move look a4 because
uh he goes lucas he wants to have bcd in
the position
but is this so okay it's very nice to
keep the knight on c4 but
okay yeah
i can slowly go king d2 king c2 and free
up that rook
yeah that's what he is doing but still
king cc runs into bishop g7
check so it's not so easy
i mean it's a very very complex and
difficult position
king c2 played and now white's rook is
in the game
magnus down to a minute as is maxime
a very tense situation because a very
crucial match for magnus if he wants his
chances to keep going
he needs to create something in this end
game
can white just go knight d2 here peter
then you go king e5
ranking e5 yeah because look protects
the bishop yeah that's
very important so knight d to king e5
luke takes e4 king d5 and luke protects
the bishop
that's uh i mean it looks like white got
everything but it's
not clear if he can really benefit ah
but okay this was this was perfect
timing
this was perfect timing look before
played
so black continues to try for
counteractivity so after knight d6
you're just going to trade it off for
king e7 rook d4
yeah i mean probably first look before
but
i mean this is
okay very very hard to judge yeah very
hard to judge
and look at this magnus down to 20
seconds yeah he's hesitating he's not
sure himself i mean it's very tricky but
yeah rookie six this gives safety and
he will be pulling up and also he will
have this look g4 f4 idea hitting the
pawn structure and then get access to
the h4 weakness
this is this is magnus's plan
oh that's very nice rook g4 and f4 is
the way to go probably after rook g4 he
has to go rook
f5 king f5 as well yeah you are just in
time to
to activate yeah so it's not easy
he returned with the look so he wants to
go look dc king d2 probably then also
to get king to absolutely look to
destroy a structure he's probably just
in time in that line
um he wanted to provoke this fc3 in
order to have king f5 king f4 and also
not to let white's king
go to g4 later on but i mean magnus
doesn't mind this because he
got he cemented his look but okay they
are down to nine seconds on the clock
this is bullet just
nine seconds on the clock and the
question is how do you improve he finds
the f4 break he finds his time to do
that but that's one more pawn trade
um takes king g5 rook g for king h5
comes back rook g5 hits it
speed up very difficult to say how white
is going to improve this position now
yeah very difficult
but also to defend it it's very
difficult with this time yeah white has
all these chances activating the king
and uh
what incredible play by these two i mean
this is just
world-class level of chess in such short
time
on the clock just and magnus finds his
king
he finds a way to get his king into the
game gives up the g2 pawn
and now he's winning because he he wins
the c5 pawn yeah
magnus carlsen catching up
seven eight is the score and this
is potentially the last game of the
three minute segment
yeah and we see exactly the same
situation that maxim is still leading uh
with one point and he has the white
pieces before the last game
and now we gonna see a burling clash
in in blitz very interesting to see how
it
how this will
develop we don't get to see so we
haven't seen so much berlin in the
in the past two matches that we've
commented on for the speed chess
championship
it's not a very blitz line
yeah it feels like it's just way too
complex to play it in a blitz game but
i mean these are two incredible experts
with lot of lot of experience so very
very interesting to see
how this theoretical debate because
actually it's a theoretical debate
that's the
biggest danger of all these berlins not
to mix up all the move orders there are
so many
finesses here and and so on and we all
remember that incredible win that hikaru
had over maxime i think peter in this
killing open
where he beat maxine in the berlin was
it again no no it was maxim who beat
hikaru in this wonderful yeah i mean in
the h5 line yeah maximizing
usually if white wins against the
berlin maxim is involved in that game
yeah that's kind of the that's how
things go because
a part of him i don't really remember
anyone legally winning against the
against the berlin that is true
knight e7 played and white goes knight
f4 so the big question in all these
setups is for black to complete his
development
get the bishop in the rook out e6 is
white's plan
yeah i mean if white gets e16 nicely
it's it's very nice for white
black is doing everything to stop that
yeah okay six trying to
protect the e6 square it's all about the
v6 square
even at the cost of spawn sacrifice
white can often
sacrifice it
and look at this maxim is almost one
minute ahead on the clock
this is this is exactly the reason why
people are afraid
to play the berlin and black wants to go
g5
next and bring the bishop out as well as
potentially threaten g4
at some point
yeah also do g8 kind of people g5 but it
runs into knight h5 knight f6 so
you have to you have to calculate very
precisely knight g6 i like this move a
lot
black targets this powerful knight from
f4 this knight
needs to be eliminated knight d3 of
course
white keeps this knight
bishop f5 and at night slowly starts to
look like a
real berlin for black because for for a
moment it looked like
things went out of control but still
still you have to cover this do you
sacrifice this pawn with c4 or you
play rook c6 you don't want to go b6
with the look on a6 yeah he goes for
this
pawn sacrifice it's typical
now white and there is no real way to
defend the spawn you go c5 but white
black could trade on e4 and pick up that
pawn on c5
yeah and it's it still gets very messy i
mean look c4 runs into bishop f2 tweak
and so black cannot capture the i mean
white cannot
uh he's gone for it peter and here you
were pointing out that rook c4 pinning
this and trying to destroy doesn't work
because a bishop f2 picks up the rook
yeah so the question is e6 yeah and e6
is on the board
you destroyed the structure but then
there you go
has to go fe6 or is f5 something worth
considering he's gone fe-6 because you
don't want to keep that pawn alive
rook g4 e5 is an option here no e5 is
not an option here because white has the
trick of taking on c5 so he had to move
away with the knight on e7
rook g7 now is met by rook g7 bishop g7
knight f5
so white instead decides to trade and
show basically
oops oh wow this was missed
what a trick what a trick by maximum
look at this he's still two minutes
on the clock i mean this oh my god this
is why we are calling him the big expert
off of the berlin yeah he does it again
he does it again he beat he's going to
beat
two of the world's best players in blitz
he
he beat hikaru in in berlin and now it
looks like he's on his way to beat
magnus this is
incredible peter yeah but however i
still believe that maximum would love to
change all these victories for the win
that he missed against grishok in the
candidates because
that mean would have given him even more
than winning any of these games
by the way he he played a wonderful game
there and
he came up with some new idea and
everything and
it was really very bad luck that he
didn't
convert that that position
talking about this is this so easy i
mean i understand you have piece up and
you have a bishop which is
it shouldn't be enough are you going to
either pick up the h or the e pawn now
because e5 runs into rook h4 king e4 and
then
pick the pawn up rook f5 king e2 rook f6
runs into rook e5 so he's got to go e5
but now this rook on f5 is just stuck on
on this side white simply brings his
king to e4
yeah and it's very important also that
you don't take i mean you don't play
this a4 pawn because
these stops and if you take them not the
spawn structure is broken bishop on d4
will control everything
yeah there are no me even yeah okay just
anything wins now
and magnus resigns and with that
with that peter we are going into a
bullet section with
maxine leading by two points
yeah it's it's incredible i mean okay it
cannot be more exciting
just amazing yeah just just amazing and
also i mean this one
in the berlin it was a master class by
maxime
incredible and like you said if white
wins
with the berlin you know who's playing
white it's maxine vasher de graf
with that we're going to go into a short
break don't go anywhere
because an insane section of 30 minutes
of
one plus one is coming up and we know
that the world champion
never gives up but boy is maxine playing
incredible chess we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
okay i'm ready i am supposed to
checkmate black
okay i know that queen could go
yay i got it all right this is easy
next one white to play and win okay um
well i can go here oh
something with the night i know it's
something with the night but i can't
take this
oh why didn't i do that magnus calls in
sergey karaki new york
2016. i was in new york when he played
this
game i should know what he did
i should know what you did okay i'm just
gonna go for a queen here
needs to be something with the queen
queen goes here then king can take the
queen
uh what other pieces do i have i also
hmm
[Music]
i'm gonna try the queen here and i did
it yay
i'm just as good as the world champion
magnus carlson that's the feeling i have
anyway
i'm gonna study on accessible every day
it's time to take control of your
journey towards chess mastery
magnus carlsen introduces chessable the
definitive solution
for studying chess movetrainer uses the
science of spaced repetition
to identify your strengths and eliminate
your weaknesses
there's no need to set up a board
remember which page you're on or keep
track of all the moves you miss move
trainer empowers you to go from the
opening to the end game
with confidence it's a seamless
effective
and fun way to study chess choose from
one of the largest
online chess libraries in the world with
hundreds of titles
ranging from classic books through to
our exclusive
chessable courses including over 100
free courses
get expert insights from international
master john bartholomew grand master sam
shankland international master christoph
zulecki grandmaster simon
williams world champion magnus carlsen
and hundreds of other instructors get
started now and join our growing
community of over 100
000 chess enthusiasts at chesable.com
tool here ladies and gentlemen as you
can see in all its glory you can see the
notation you can also see the engine
evaluation next to each move
and also how long they spend what i like
is
you can make your own moves on the board
you can check the alternatives
to what the players did and even for the
moves you make you get
the computer evaluation here fantastic
you get it
quicker and better as a premium member
such as yours truly
but i also like there is a chat function
you can
exchange things with people from all
over the world
if you want to see something else let's
say you're watching a tournament you
want to see all the games at once
no problem displaying i have no idea how
many games there are like 128 games at
the same time
you can do it more this is a team
competition you click on multiboard
that's beautiful you can see all the
eight games going on
at once
you can see the games and standings
which we got oh click around
games standings here yeah
analysis if we click on that tab that's
good
you can see that it's a great little
graphical illustration
the red line is zero that is the
absolute even
mark and if the white bars are go up the
further up they go the bigger the
advantage
and the black bars show a black
advantage
then there is a database and here we get
the alternatives and we if we click on a
move in the database
bam it gets played on the board
fantastic and then the pgn can even be
downloaded off your choice
yeah and one of the great things i like
to see as well is
when we get a video from the playing
i like to see them in their seats
nervous
you feel the tension you feel like
you're there don't you chess is really
becoming
a spectator's internet support great
that we can see that i also love to see
um the fact that we can get in some of
our friends
to join us during the broadcast and it's
all interactive that's what we love and
a lot of overview functions a lot of
great functions there ladies and
gentlemen make sure you
take advantage of oh let's get back to
the commentary keep tweeting us hashtag
c24 live
we love to hear from you ask us anything
about mainly about lauren's
if you have other questions they're also
well also send us anything you like
about
jan
c24 live absolutely
welcome back everybody we are about to
kick off
the bullet section of the format it's a
one minute with a one second increment
magnus carlsen playing catch up he's
behind by
two points peter this is the dream
scenario that we were discussing for
maxime at the start that he needs to get
the lead in the five and the three
minutes section before he takes on
magnus in the bullet
yeah absolutely and i mean the point is
that it puts a lot of lot of pressure on
magnus i mean it's
not the comfortable situation that like
hikaru was yesterday that equalized the
match uh
[Music]
at the end and when the bullet started
it was
equal yeah the score was equal now a lot
of lot of pressure on magnus and
usually i mean when you are under
pressure you cannot just
play with the flow yeah you very much
care about the result and
uh i'm very very excited and interested
to see how magnus will handle this
situation it's a big challenge
a lot at stake the qualifying spot into
the finals to face hikaru nakamura
uh the finals are tomorrow
and that's how our bracket looks hikaru
qualified by
with his win over wesley so and magnus
behind by two points against maxime now
i know a lot of us have been saying that
maxime has
incredible control over the clock in the
five minutes in the three minutes
portion we've seen him ahead on time
majority of the games but one minute
is it completely different it's it's a
different game altogether
even though you're shot on the clock
peter you start with one minute the
psychology is totally different
yeah totally different because usually i
mean
maxim was always up on the clock and was
in a comfortable situation with
one and a half minutes and so on but
here of course when
clocks dig down very very fast for both
of them
that brings new dynamic maybe exactly
this new dynamic is what
magnus needs because he has been
struggling of course
there was this heartbreaking moment with
the mouse sleep okay
i think that it was already not that
heartbreaking because
the possession was probably a draw and
magnus was already very very angry any
way of
not having that that position definitely
the mouse lift did not help and and that
was a very very
crucial moment of the match because with
that win magnus would have just
equalized the score and he would have
two wins
straight wins and a lot of lot of
confidence
so many many twists so far big roller
coaster emotional device so on
i i don't know what to say magnus is
definitely
going to need to get his a game on
because again
i think it's all about getting the
momentum going right from the word go
and with that we do have the word go as
the games
i think have started peter or we don't
we still have a couple
of um we still have a minute or two
before liftoff
but yes if if maxime and also the thing
with bullet is it's very difficult to
stop any kind of bleeding
you know it's not like you can
neutralize or just consolidate if you've
lost the game and come back because
it's always going to be a decisive
result with this time control
super important to not go until if
magnus has to bounce back he needs those
early wins
in this format otherwise peter if it
starts well for maxime
i don't see magnus coming back in this
match
yeah at least it's it's gonna be very
very tough i don't have any experience
that how many bullet games usually the
players play
during this 30 minutes i i'm not
experienced enough for that
but uh definitely what magnus needs to
score a win
right in the very first game because he
starts with the white pieces just also
to set the tone that
you know yes i understand i'm training
but i'm here i
know that this is the last section and
and i'm going to control it no matter if
you are leading or not maxim and exactly
that's what
uh maxim will try to stop i mean not not
to let happen and here we go
magnus goes for the bishop b5 sicilian
and it's on the one thing we do know
about this format is and we've seen it
in hikaru's matches as well that the
players have this little trick that when
they're leading they try to burn the
clock and the time down
as much as possible so that the number
of games
are not as many and i think that's a
very important uh
part of gameplay in this format it's
going to be interesting if maxine
follows that same
uh same way of playing as we've seen
hikaru do it so successfully
yeah well to be honest i'm very happy
that so far today we haven't witnessed
that strategist
but it was also not clear whom bullet
will benefit and the match was also so
wide open that it was just very natural
that
uh things are out of control and look at
this magnus
goes for a line which in my mind uh
i felt like there had been quite a lot
of games with it so it shouldn't come as
a surprise but
by judging at the speed how the players
are playing and maxim goes for b4 yeah
this is very interesting
cb queen takes b4 but queen b4 is on
this uh
this is maybe a mistake i think queen b4
is a mistake
is knight b5 an option here but
i mean how do you knight b5 the point is
that white
black has knight e5 black is actually
threatening knight e5 i think peter here
yeah but also maybe yeah knight b5 but
actually
bishop e4 now bishop e4 yeah
knight c7 checking the eight what is
going on here
well actually magnus is
losing no bishop d2 i mean i almost said
he's losing because he might end up in
some bad end game
but look at this down to 20 seconds on
the clock
down to 20 seconds and the point is that
if you trade off everything on e4 black
just has an extra pawn and
magnus trying to create an attack but i
don't see how he's going to do it
he goes into the end game black has an
extra pawn
peter this is a dream start for maxime
yeah okay now magnus tries with knight
g5 yeah you have to go knight e5 comes
bishop c3 i mean magnus has to save this
game somehow that's
that's very very important and rook b8
is an option
but at least one can claim that by
forcing d4
he he got this e4 square but on the
other hand what this
e4 square gives but yeah king f1 he
tries to put
forth i mean blockade king is coming to
dc
magnus fighting for a draw here f5 and
down to 16 seconds maxine with 20
seconds hits the knight the knight has
to go back to
d2 yeah magnus is fighting for his life
because he cannot take on d4 because e1
bishop will be hanging so
that's an incredible line and he creates
he could go e4 now yes and that's it
this
is this could
just end very badly for white look at
those two pawns e4
and d3 all black has to do is get a
successful
e3 d6 but also look at white's grip i
mean
white is like unbelievably controlling
the board yeah he got his king to d5
in fact anyone can win this game now
it's it's completely out of control
magnus down to eight seconds peter
yeah and now it's
oh and he goes knight c7 knight day6 so
he's got a way to defend the pawn
from queen steel now white is the one
pressing
because indeed white is going to pick up
all the pawns on the
on the king side
picks up d3 picks up h6
yeah but he's just in time to hold yeah
incredible
king e4 king f3 coming in i thought that
black white perhaps could have picked up
the pawn on h6 but then black would have
stopped the entry and that's it this
king on f3 is strong enough to stop
everything takes on g3 game over
what a save magnus cannot be unhappy
with that result
yeah this this is a moral boost because
i think he
he understood that yeah probably and how
he defended because
i mean judging that you can let these
pawns come yeah i mean he for this
we kind of screamed that okay that's it
and exactly when i screamed as well i
understood no the game is just beginning
because the magnus was very nicely
feeling the dynamics of the position
with five seconds on the clock amazing
stuff
[Music]
and we see this cc sicilian i think that
uh johan sebastian christian then wrote
a chessable
course on on it and there was this uh
tweet from him like uh i and magnus
yeah i'm following what's happening you
know peter that is already step one
and that's something that the chat has
brought up too many times that this
needs to happen we've been talking about
it since the skilling open
yeah definitely and you know i i enjoy
all these tweets
reading it and and so on and uh now so
with this chesapeake courses we see that
the players are promoting uh the forces
and
yes because when johan sebastian wrote
this course or it went online then the
very next day
uh magnus played it against the
neapolitan you remember in this crazy
this reality stuff and there was all
these tweets between the players yeah a
lot of
a lot of actions but what i see over the
board is that
magnus now very much loves this position
for from the back side
that makes a lot of sense that bishop on
c6 he's just going to move
he's got 94 i really like that move but
wait what's happening after knight c6
exactly peter
yeah that's the big question i mean
queen edge to king f1 king h1 king e2
queen take g2
hitting on f2 hitting the knight on c6
but then you pick up the rook you go
queen
i mean i don't cb6 wow very nice
very very nice because if the knight
goes to e7 then the knight will be
trapped there
it's just trapped that's an incredible
idea
and now he could go queen at schwann
queen g2 yeah because this defends the
knight on g4
nice move threatening knight g6 so
there's a little trick on the board that
black needs to be careful about he goes
e5 hitting that rook
also making plays for the rook on d6 to
defend knight g6
yeah but not this is completely crazy
because after e5
the bishop is alive the knight is not
left anymore
i don't know what to say
well he he wants to have six now h4
queen takes f2 is
this his idea but at the end of the day
he will be pissed on it's not
doesn't seem to work because you don't
even have 93 check after king d1
he's just gone for rook f3 what's going
on he looks
again like it's not enough for black
yeah and it was so beautiful i mean this
this idea i mean clearly
magnus has spotted this uh d6 idea
when he went for knight g4 and then to
to
misplay this this is really unfortunate
magnus down to six seconds on the clock
takes on e5 yes this looks like it's
going to be
over peter just bishop goes to f7 and
the rook is free now to get it into the
game
yeah uh rook h2
h5 at least but h5 king f4 g4 king gets
the m3
he wins it yeah that's a very nice line
so the point and that's it because
magnus needs to keep getting more games
in let's just show this quickly peter
king f3 you don't have h4 because the
rook on g4 hangs
white will go on to pick up the g3 pawn
and of course
we go again no h4 this time peter
yeah no h4 because okay the point is
that after a break
you feel like you're open and it's
probably ready for it
he goes for the line that he's employed
in the five minute segment
and e6
but what is this i mean it looks like
white is
white is just uh i mean got the maximum
that you can ever dream of against the
glenfeld
but look at maxim's clock he's taken two
seconds so far
well i mean he knows that you know the
possession is so bad that at least
let me be up on the clock
[Music]
knight x ec that's that's a surprise
i mean i felt like he wants to go bishop
c6 keep this knight on f5 as long as
he can this is a completely lost
structure but he
he hopes for queen g5
but how do you get queen g5
not just luke g1 maybe i mean trade of
this active rook and
the rook shivan black could play queen
g5 because after
94 you've got rook g2 check he's gone
for queen g5
knight e4 is not a threat because of
rook g2 as well as queen g4 just lots of
options
so nothing to worry there uh white has
to trade the rooks and now this queen on
g3 i like rook f8 coming in next all the
pieces coming into the game
yeah i think that this is really really
unpleasant because you feel that
it should be winning for white but on
the other hand it's not trivial and you
feel that you have to burn time to
to find the win and you can see it any
time and look at it i
i don't like white's position here at
all
uh peter it looks specially in with 22
seconds and that king on d3
your heart is not doing very well i
think yeah usually my heart doesn't do
that well but after c
for king d2 my heart is already you know
more smiling because i feel that i'm
more or less but look f2 yeah everything
comes
it's it's completely crazy but look f1
yeah at least
that's a nice move that's a nice move so
rook f1 runs into knight g3 you're
getting rid of the pin
and now the h pawn and bishop h6 not
just the pawn but bishop h6
uh hitting the easy pawn force which
actually makes the last time
this is a very nice idea he does it and
queen e4 has to be played to defend the
3.95 is also an option yeah knight d5 is
maybe
strong but maybe not necessarily cc
check played wow
what a game by maxine peter i
am king d2 bishop takes easy check this
is winning he finds it
he finds it this is over this is over
queen e3 knight c4 king c to queenie to
just everything
that's it and magnus had to design to go
for the next game
peter maxine leads with
four points yeah i mean this is seven
and a half to eleven and a half
and eighteen minutes remaining for the
world champion to make a comeback
yeah that that would maybe be the
biggest comeback ever in this format
yeah i mean it's
mine i mean magnus is he's known to be a
comeback king but this is just
this is very close to being impossible
right now yeah especially because
uh the way how maxim is playing yeah i
mean sports every tactic
he plays very very fast i mean in the
previous game we have seen that yeah he
even doesn't care about
the opening phase anymore he just wants
to play super fast
still bad position but keeping chances
keeping chances and and now magnus stays
the same you know i don't want to
equalize i don't want anything i just
want to get a position where i can play
a tempo put pressure on the clock and
look at this first time
magnus is up on the clock
but white has a wonderful position
however we have seen that wonderful
position doesn't mean that much here
there are all kinds of knight f5 tweaks
but probably magnus feels that he's in
time to
to neutralize this with some knight g6
later on
and the first time maxim is really
falling shot on the clock invite
goodnight f5
white black just takes gf5 queen g5
knight g6 ef5
and then h6 there's eight six in the end
which would solve all problems
so knight f5 doesn't work he improves
the bishop to c4
now threatening moves like knight g5 at
some point hitting on f7
uh has to be a little careful about d5
he's gone for c5 instead yeah this is i
think not psychological because
magnus sees that he's up on the clock he
wants to close the position so that
there will be no direct
confrontation and just try to play
try to play fast and uh and the long
game
a long game and i like what he's doing
maxine is down to 14
seconds uh does white want to get f4
no white wants to get this knight to c4
i mean it's it's lovely but
uh the question is oh no knights
knights perfect for black
so queen e7 rook h4 is also not a threat
queen g5
uh shrook f7
is coming how is black defending it with
the knight on h6
yeah all of a sudden white is doing
great
because white also has some look f6
ideas
yeah knight back yeah you have to
control this f6 square because the maxim
had this look f6
chance and just look at the speed
with which the players are playing just
mind blowing speed yeah
knight g1 is coming that's a very nice
re-routing of the knight to f3 to move
this rook from e5
yeah typical classical spanish idea
knight to fc but now they look on f4
is is threatened to be trapped some
somewhere
magnus needs to get his knight to e5 but
it's it's almost impossible yeah
so now takes with the d-pawn that's
interesting
yeah and now now magnus in his element i
mean now he feels that maybe you know i
can do something in this end game
but still yeah this breaking the
structure immediately not giving time
for black to
look fate now is not possible because
you trade a knight f3
yeah now white is just better with this
yeah he can take and bishop g4
king f6 king g4
how is white improving so you want to go
bishop c6 and d6 d7
but bishop c6 has bishop c8 check
ah but i mean maybe here maxine made a
mistake no i mean knowing hikaru
strategy he could have maybe
burned much more time on the clock in
this bishop end game
you know because black can also he knows
that peter doesn't approve of that so he
decided not
okay or he's just way too confident he's
plus four after all
that's true that's actually a really big
score and with 14 minutes left on the
clock
uh it's pretty much go big or go home
for magnus he needs to score a win peter
yeah he needs to score now in and he
goes for a very very sharp line in this
bishop easily
nigey for najdorf
again a big theoretical clash i mean
it's it also signals you know how
important
this this match is for manus as well
because it's not like you know the score
is not going well and then he
you know he doesn't want to show any
opening idea no
is he's actually trying very hard to to
put pressure on maksim as much as he can
i think the one thing that we know about
magnus is that he hates losing and
every tournament he is just playing to
win it and this is the first time that
he's returning to the speed chess
championship
since 2017. wow that's knight f5 i mean
you
you you had no no light to allow this
knights
now black is busted now black is busted
and how is he just takes on f6 so bishop
f6 he's going to pick up the h6
pawn and this looks like exactly what
magnus need
needed now maxine needs to just keep the
clock going peter he needs to let this
run out as much as he can
fight for as long as he can yeah
but i mean how long can he fight here
because he might just get
crushed but okay you already don't care
right
you just play you just do what you can
to keep the game going it doesn't
i'm sure maxine realizes this is
completely lost although he has created
a threat on b2 now
yeah he has he has some chances i mean
and you know there's always queen a5
that could come into the game
uh if you make a move like b3 so maybe
we are calling it too soon right now
no i think it was much more lost before
now yeah
magnus goes 97 but hang on the rook b
2 kings c1 rook b2 a bishop
peter bishop b2 bishop g7 was a big
threat he played c
this is a competition
[Music]
oh my god i mean bishop ac was was
winning for
was it i'm not okay it's just too quick
everything
it doesn't matter because i don't think
magnus is
uh maxine is losing anymore yeah but now
white is in control i mean uh
white's position looked very very
dangerous suspicious
but now it's stabilized again but things
are out of control i mean
93 runs into queen h8 so he has to be
careful about queen h8 queen b8 so he
gives a check on f2 will he just trade
off the queens
night disney
yeah this is very bad news for magnus
because he he has to burn so much time
to convert this
better than game
and also magnus must be kicking himself
to just mess up that completely winning
position after the opening
now he picks up the a6 pawn next yeah
but this is still
quite uh quite a journey
yeah okay four and not really clear
because rookie seven you want to go king
f6
no knights knights of in f6 and it's
game over but i mean it will still
require moves and
naduki seven check and a7
that's it
yeah and that's it maxime resigns
okay magnus starts he's come back but
will it be enough it's a long journey
peter
yeah it's tm minus three and now he uses
the aryakin
the alakan defense
it has served him well in the playoff
against hikaru right
i mean we were commenting on on that
game
in the final kiva finals there was some
incredibly
sharp i think he car went for the four
pawns variation and things went
completely out of control
peter if you had to give a percentage
chance on magnus making a comeback here
what would it be we started this match
with the 60 40 to magnus
[Laughter]
i think that that says it all
i i don't know i mean it just i mean i'm
rooting for magnus not to to
to make as exciting fight as possible
but i'm i'm not sure how much is still
possible here
not fisher saying it would be a miracle
but it's possible
it'd definitely be a miracle i mean how
many minutes left
we've got nine minutes remaining so he
has to win all the games all the games
every single game from now i mean once
low end it's over
[Music]
that is correct wait rookie three oh no
queen is protected yeah i am losing my
mind as well
yeah i understand i mean i lost it long
ago
if you just lost it now it's it's fine
it's great i mean
this is but but look at this whenever
malmo says
he gets a lovely position almost right
out of the opening it
i mean is this alejand events really so
good but if it
if it would be so good he would be using
it more often yeah not just as a
surprise
wow look at that so now he's
he's made us he's created his chances in
this game as well peter
uh lots of activity by black's pieces
the e3 knight is
pinned by the bishop and
can he he so he can't currently pick up
the b4 pawn because the rook on e5
hangs but he could just pick up the e3
pawn
but then white trades the queens and
picks up the c6 pawn
so a lot of pawns hanging everywhere
yeah this this typically annoying
position that you feel that it should be
winning but there is no clear
direct way i like c5 moving away and now
move like rookie three is also possible
he's gone for it rookie three fe3 queen
g3 you trade that off first and then you
go bishop e3
yeah but white gets this a5 counter play
i mean it's
it's really amazing that whenever maxim
is in trouble
uh somehow his position yeah okay one
this is still chance next time but still
but this is a million pawns for black
and again this is completely
this should be just winning for black
right peter
well it looks uh but i mean look at this
white has incredible coordination with
bishop on e4 the
four pawns don't move on the on the king
side
white's king is coming closer now white
is safe now i
is not even worse because you just don't
have a way to advance your pawns anymore
white has found the structure to stop
the b4 and the c3 pawn
and this g4 pawn is stopping counter
play on the king side
incredible yeah okay this was nice that
at least magnus managed to provoke this
pawn to gc because then
he will always have this target with his
rook
and finally the king king activates
itself king b7
if this ends in a draw i think it's the
end of the road for the world champion
yeah definitely i mean time is time is
ticking
c2 yeah so magnus goes for the gc pawn
but
what are his winning chances here okay
he relies on
g2 check forcing the king away and tries
to get f5 in so that he gets three
connected passers
that's that's the chance
but now white will start checking
okay five king e6
bishop fc g4 king f6
yeah he needs this look freaking g5 h4
now
now black is making progress that bishop
actually looked like a bit of waste of
time he could have started with the
checks already and
now this king g3 now
he's gone for rookie three yeah okay c
and then okay now look c5
king g3 yeah he wins it's
it's incredible yeah wow
look f5 and takes an h1 and that is over
and and maxime doesn't burn time he
doesn't play for
uh for burning the clock but he just
continues to the next game
yeah i think this is uh this is showing
respect and uh
i mean he wants to win the match uh to
add them on the board i mean this is the
this is the classical approach
pure sportsmanship knight c3 played
97 and
peter there's just time i think for
three games so again if magnus has to
make his comeback he needs to win every
game
yeah he has won two and uh fourth mark
seemed to go to the
karokan i mean it's i'm not sure that
maxim is feeling so comfortable in these
structures
definitely not having enough experience
but also magnus is playing uh
magnus is playing a line which i'm not
sure he really has so much x but g4 he's
winning the piece
is he knight dtx e5 followed by queen
takes d4 no
it's it's not knight t takes e5
no he goes bishop g4 okay so it was so
mortals because
i mean what they have been showing in
the last uh
one one and a half two hours was insane
but yeah they are also showing some
weakness
and if they would not be showing
weakness in uh in the bullet game that
that would be just insane
peter i've just got confirmation that in
case the match ends
with 12 12 that would mean four more
games off the same bullet segment with
one plus one and in case that's a tie as
well then we move on to the armageddon
that's well that's what we want to see
you know
i mean please entertain us yes or maybe
maybe maksim is just
understanding it's not about
sportsmanship he won't just want
the people to enjoy it as as much as
possible
but yeah magnus still has a lot to catch
up okay now he's
uh about to win his third game in a row
which is still bringing him only closer
but it's it's not enough yet
by far not enough yet
yeah knight f4 i mean those are these
little moves that that really
make you very upset because you feel
that
yeah it should be winning but i mean
it's not elementary
if magnus loses the d7 pawn then the
chances of winning this game quickly
are are vanishing and it's happening now
it's happening he's lost the d7 pawn
yeah i mean converting this will take a
lot of lot of time but we will still
have enough for just one more game peter
even if he comes down uh because there
are two minutes left on the
on the clock for the match to finish so
we're definitely going to have one more
game after this
he needs to he needs to win this game in
two minutes yeah
he needs to win this game within the
next two minutes yes
yeah and i think it's headed there he's
managed to pick up sir
k2 is a threat which is why he moved
away with the bishop
uh
[Music]
and i have to say peter winning three
games in a row to even get to here just
unbelievable play by magnus yeah it's
unbelievable but you know
i feel like maybe the sportsmanship the
incredible sportsmanship by magnus wheel
will come to haunt him because
if he would have not designed that
previous game he could have still
gained some 30 more seconds maybe on on
that game
it's uh it's dramatic
and maximum designs yeah so basically oh
my god
this is an insane match we have one more
bullet game remaining
and magnus at 11 maxim at 12
it's all down to this game
yeah this
this is epic i mean i don't know what to
say i
have never seen something like this
never heard anything of like this
you can just never write him off
this has come like coming back from the
dead i mean following up
four games down to 11 last minutes of
the whole match and then scoring three
big wins
just unbelievable yeah and how he got
there yeah i mean it was
already he was in a very very uh i mean
in a very bad mood yeah he he missed
many chances
things didn't go right maxine was using
all the chances punishing him for every
single mistake
and and he finds the stance and look at
this he got c5 in and he got
he got a game magnus got a game i mean
the dream scenario with the black pieces
after move six seven you already have a
full-fledged fight
and uh and if this game magnus
manages to squeeze out the win in this
one then we see
four more games of bullet with one plus
one time control
and in case that's a tie as well we move
on to the armageddon
i mean completely crazy position then
you take on eight seven now
yeah but do you wanna do you wanna waste
time for for that pawn it's
it's a bit not anymore that's not an
option anymore
yeah but now it was very nice for magnus
that with queen b6 he protected the e6
pawn he didn't have to go knight f8
he gets the dynamic he has queen c6
hitting the g2 pawn
okay white plays f3 take six and what
next because white has a very solid
stable position
and now he's just going to put pressure
along the e file on the e6 pawn and
trade and
pick that up with knight e6 but he
decides not to
yeah because actually yeah maxim wants
to keep this structure because black's
bishop on c8 is dead the king on e8 is
vulnerable
magnus down to 14 seconds on the cloak
that's a very good point peter that
actually the e6 pawn
having it on the board is more
beneficial for white than not having it
on the board
yeah maxime opened the position up
yeah he opened it up with d4 which
looked strange but he wanted to get his
knife
next king h1 and queen c2 and the queen
enters the game and
that would be that would be disastrous
how is white fighting
can white just go queen c2 now then you
want to go rook f6 he goes knight g6
instead
what an incredible game magnus down to
four seconds
yeah and that's it that's it yeah that's
it there is no way back from here i mean
this is oh my god
unbelievable maxine with 23 seconds on
his clock
yeah peter that's it
maxine wins he wins 11
13 and with that that's a very sweet way
into the finals not only do you get that
spot but you do it by defeating the
world champion which
is as we know no easy task whatsoever
but peter not just the score incredible
quality of play by maxine
yeah absolutely i mean also magnus was
putting up an incredible fight okay
clearly
magnus was not in his best shape but
you know this best shape thing is like
this that you show
shape how much your opponent lacks and
it
a lot of credit goes to maxime that you
know i mean he was
driving magnus crazy he didn't let him
settle in his comfort zone and
and show his real strength he created
problems all the time and
finally he was a deserved deserved
winner for today's match
and as we saw magnus scored those three
critical wins back to back to
build his chance but then the final game
taken away by maxime
and peter it all came down to those to
that big
two-point margin that he had before
going into the bullet section
yeah that was that was crucial that was
vital
that actually forced magnus to to take
more risk i mean not to play the
the usual chess he he likes to and uh
yeah basically maxine made perfect use
of it but
also this comeback what magnus started
at the very end i mean winning three
games in a row and
and almost doing it on the other hand
also
incredible kudos to maxim by making all
this was an incredible fight
what if i just how we like it and we've
actually been treated to two
amazing semi-finals peter the hikaru
wesley match
was was amazing and today's final
one that i think few would have
predicted from maxime to come on top at
the end
and with that we get a maxine washer
regraft taking on hikaru nakamura
in the final you don't want to miss that
join us for that tomorrow
and also more good news more chess stuff
for all of us
there is a 40 discount on going premium
currently which has 24
use this use the code speed 20.
let me just confirm that yeah it's speed
20 for 40
off with that you support everything
that chess 24 does
but also more importantly and more
interestingly
and more everything you get to be a part
of the champions chester because this
year
the audience will get a chance to vote
back players would pack
their favorite players into the tour
you'll also get access
to all the to all the resources on
chess24.com to improve your own game
plus challenge the world's best players
to different chess formats
but for now it's a wrap from us join us
tomorrow for the finals
good night peter yeah thank you bye bye
tanya bye everyone
[Music]
[Music]
okay i'm ready i am supposed to
checkmate black
okay i know that queen could go here
but then ah the night the black knight
can stop me if i go here
okay so i'm gonna go here yay
i got it all right this is easy next one
white to play and win
okay um well i can go here oh
ah something with the knight i know it's
something with the knight but i can't
take this
oh why didn't i do that magnus calls in
sergey karaki new york
2016. i was in new york when he played
this
game i should know what he did
i should know what you did okay i'm just
gonna go for a queen here
needs to be something with the queen
queen goes here then king can take the
queen
uh what other pieces do i have i also
hmm
[Music]
i'm gonna try the queen here and i did
it yay
i'm just as good as the world champion
magnus carlsen that's the feeling i have
anyway
i'm gonna study on chesable every day